ASSEMBLY MEMBER RIVAS NOTICES
THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM. THE
SERGEANTS AT ARMS WILL PREPARE
THE CHAMBER BRING IN THE ABSENT
MEMBERS AND THE CLERK WILL CALL
THE ROLL AGUIAR-CURRY ARAMBULA
OUR QUE HAN BERMAN BIGELOW.
BLOOM BURNER **** BATH BONTA
BRO. YRC CALDERON CARRILLO
CERVANTES CHAU CHEN DAVID CHIU
CHOI KANSEN CHU COOLEY COOPER.
CUNNINGHAM DALY DEEP EGGMAN
FLORA FONG FRAZIER FRIEDMAN
GABRIEL GALLAGHER CRISTINA
GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA GIPSON
GLORIA GONZALEZ IS GRAY. MASON
HOLDEN IRWIN JONES SAWYER KALRA
KAMLAGER-DOVE. KILEY LACKEY
LEVINE LIMóN OWN LOW
MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS MAYES
MCCARTY MEDINA MELENDEZ MULLIN
MURATSUCHI NAZARIAN OBERNOLTE
O'DONNELL PATTERSON
PETRIE-NORRIS QUIRK QUIRK SILVA
RAMOS RADIUS THREE OF US ROBERT
RIVAS RODRIGUEZ RUBIO SALAS
SANTIAGO SMITH. STONE TING
VOEPEL WALDRON WEBER WICKS WOOD
MISTER SPEAKER
. MEMBERS A
QUORUM IS PRESENT. A QUORUM IS
PRESENT IN THE ASSEMBLY. WE ASK
THAT OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS IN
THE REAR OF THE CHAMBER AND IN
THE GALLERY PLEASE STAND FOR
THE PRAYER. TODAY'S PRAYER WILL
BE OFFERED BY OUR ASSEMBLY
CHAPLAIN THE REVEREND PADDY
O'SHEA. PLEASE JOIN ME IN A
MOMENT OF REFLECTION. AMONG THE
GREAT POET OF THE GOLDEN AGE OF
THE CHINESE POETRY IS LEAD BY.
HE LIVED TWELVE CENTURIES AGO
DURING THE TANG DYNASTY. LEVI
LIVED IN TIMES OF PEACE AND
PROSPERITY THERE FELL INTO
TIMES OF REBELLION CHAOS AND
VIOLENCE ONE OF HIS POEMS CAME
TO MIND WHEN I READ AGAIN ABOUT
YET ANOTHER TRAGEDY OF
SENSELESS. VIOLENCE. TWELVE
HUNDRED YEARS AGO THE BY ROAD
OF THE BATTLES A WAR HE
WITNESSED. THE CONFLICT NEVER
STOPS. THE DYING NEVER STOPS.
NO THAT THE SWORD IS A CURSE
THING THAT THE WISE MEN USE
USES ONLY IF HE MUST. HUMANKIND
HAS NEVER BEEN LACKING THE
WISDOM TO DO THE RIGHT THING.
BUT PERHAPS WE HAVE NOT BEEN
TEACHING AND SHARING THAT WITH
THEM. THE DALAI LAMA HAS SAID.
MY WISH IS THAT. ONE DAY FORMAL
EDUCATION WILL PAY ATTENTION TO
THE EDUCATION OF THE HEART
TEACHING LOVE COMPASSION
JUSTICE FORGIVENESS MINDFULNESS
TOLERANCE MPS. WE NEED A WORLD
WIDE INITIATIVE FOR EDUCATING
HEART AND MIND IN THIS MODERN
AGE. NOW MORE ME DOWN WITH
KINDNESS AND GRATITUDE BEYOND
WORDS. THANK YOU REVEREND WE
ASK OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS TO
REMAIN STANDING AND JOIN US FOR
THE FLAG SALUTE PLEASE JOIN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER KALRA AS HE
LEADS US IN THE PLEDGE MISTER
KALRA THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
READY AGAIN. I PLEDGE
ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG. IS.
THANK YOU MAY BE SEATED.
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL ASSEMBLY CHAMBER
SACRAMENTO MONDAY AUGUST
NINETEENTH TWENTY NINETEEN
RECENTLY MET AT ONE PM ON ALL
KEVIN MULLIN SPEAKER PRO TEM OF
THE ASSEMBLY PRESIDING CHEAP
CLICKY DOTSON WILSON AT THE
DESK READ MISTER CALDERON MOVES
AND MISS WALDRON SECONDS AT THE
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL BE DISPENSED WITH.
PRESENTATIONS AND PETITIONS
THERE ARE NONE INTRODUCTION
REFERENCE TO BILLS WILL BE
DEFERRED REPORTS OF COMMITTEES
WILL BE DEEMED READ AND
AMENDMENTS DEEMED ADOPTED.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR
THERE ARE NONE. MESSAGES FROM
THE SENATE THERE ARE NONE.
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS THE
ABSENCES FOR THE DAY FOR
PERSONAL BUSINESS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER EDUARDO GARCIA AND FOR
ILLNESS ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
FRAZIER. WE ARE AT. PROCEDURAL
MOTIONS. MISTER CALDERON YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR
PROCEDURAL MOTION THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO SUSPEND
ASSEMBLY RULE ONE EIGHTEEN A TO
ALLOW ASSEMBLY MEMBERS COOLEY
KALRA MAYES TO HAVE GUESTS AND
PHOTOGRAPHERS ON THE FLOOR
TODAY AND I DON'T REMEMBER
KALRA SCHEDULE PLEASE BE SEATED
AS DESK WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH
SHALL BE THE ORDER THANK YOU I
ALSO ASK UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE FORTY
FIVE POINT FIVE TO ALLOW
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS BLOOM JONES
SAWYER GALLAGHER GONZALEZ AND
RUBIO TO SPEAK ON THE
MEASUREMENT AND MEMORY TODAY.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER AT THE REQUEST OF THE
AUTHOR SKEWS ME AT THE REQUEST
OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER CARILLO I AM
GIVING A ONE DAY NOTICE TO
REMOVE ITEM A THIRTEEN SB. TWO
EIGHTY SIX SENATE GOVERNMENTAL
ORGANIZATION COMMITTEE. FROM
THE ENACT A FILE. THE CLERK
WILL NOTE. MEMBERS WE HAVE A
NUMBER OF SPECIAL GUEST WITH US
IN THE ASSEMBLY TODAY. DOCTOR
QUIRK I BELIEVE YOUR GUESTS
HAVE ARRIVED YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
FOR IT ASKED FOR YOUR GUESTS
INTRODUCTION. MEMBERS. TWENTY
NINETEEN MARKS THE HUNDRED AND
FIFTIETH ANNIVERSARY OF THE
FORMULATION OF THE PERIODIC
TABLE. WE HAVE A NUMBER OF GAS
IN THE GALLERY HERE IN HONOR OF
WELCOME THE FOLLOWING MEMBERS
OF THE AMERICAN CHEMICAL
SOCIETY DOCTOR LEE PLEASE STAND
UP DOCTOR LEE LATIMER WHO IS
THE DIRECTOR OF THE LOCAL BAY
AREA AND NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
AMERICAN C<c.cyan> SOCIETY. DR</c>
BRIAN. BAYLESS DR EILEEN NO
TALLY. AND SARAH BRADY WHO IS
AN ALUMNUS OF THE CALIFORNIA
SCIENCE AND TECHNOLOGY OF
FELLOWSHIP PROGRAM. ALSO IN THE
GALLEY GALLERY RG AND HALEY
MANAGER STATE AND EXTERNAL
RELATIONS FROM LARGE BERKELEY.
SCOTT WILSON COMMUNITY
RELATIONS OFFICER LAWRENCE
LIVERMORE NATIONAL LAB. AND AB
GILL SAID FROM MY FELLOW FROM
MY LAST YEAR THANK YOU ALL FOR
BEING HERE. OF LARGE BURKE
LEGAL LAB IN LAWRENCE LIVERMORE
LAB WHERE I WORK FOR TWENTY SIX
YEARS AS SYNTHESIZED A TOTAL OF
TWENTY TWO NEW ELEMENTS. WHICH
ARE NOW IN THE PERIODIC TABLE
SOME OF THE BETTER KNOWN OR
CALIFORNIA. BERKELEY AND
LIVERMORIUM. PLEASE GIVE THEM
OFF WHY WARM WELCOME
. AND
MISTER MEDINA. YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR GUESTS
INTRODUCTION. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS. I STAND TO
RECOGNIZE OCTOBER FIFTH. TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN AS OSTOMY
AWARENESS DAY. ONE MILLION
AMERICANS ARE LIVING WITH AN
OSTOMY AND APPROXIMATELY ONE
HUNDRED THOUSAND YOU LIFESAVING
OSTOMY SURGERIES ARE PERFORMED
ANNUALLY IN THE UNITED STATES.
OSTOMY CAN OCCUR AT ANY AGE AND
DOES NOT LOWER LIFE EXPENSE
EXPECTANCY. AUSTIN MAYES ARE
LIFESAVERS. EFFORTS BY THE
UNITED OSTOMY ASSOCIATIONS OF
AMERICA AND IT'S OVER THREE
HUNDRED AFFILIATED SUPPORT
GROUPS AMERICANS NEEDING THESE
SURGERIES ARE BECOMING MORE
AWARE OF THE OPPORTUNITIES FOR
EDUCATION MUTUAL AID ADVOCACY
AND SUPPORT THAT ARE SUCH GREAT
BENEFIT TO THEM AND THEIR
FAMILIES I ALSO WANT TO
INTRODUCE. TO CONSTITUENTS FROM
RIVERSIDE SANDY GREEN AND
CONNIE COPPER IN THE GALLERY.
REPRESENTING THE INLAND EMPIRE
OSTOMY ASSOCIATION THANK YOU
MEMBERS FOR YOUR ATTENTION IN
THIS IMPORTANT MATTER
. A MISTER
MESS YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FROM MY
DESK IN THE REAR THE CHAMBER
FOR YOUR SPECIAL INTRODUCTION
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I SEPTEMBER IS A
SUICIDE PREVENTION MONTH. SADLY
IT TWENTY TWO UNITED STATES
VETERANS COMMIT SUICIDE DALY
AND TODAY WE ARE HERE TO HONOR
SOMEONE WHO WORKS TO SOLVE FOR
THIS PROBLEM TIRELESSLY. IT IS
MY HONOR TO INTRODUCE RETIRED
MASTER SERGEANT ANDRE RUSH A
TWENTY THREE YEAR DECORATED
COMBAT VETERAN MASTER SERGEANT
RUSHES CAREER INCLUDED SERVING
FOR THREE CHAIRMAN OF THE JOINT
CHIEFS OF STAFF AS WELL AS THE
CHIEF OF STAFF FOR THE UNITED
STATES ARMY. CHEF RUSH IS MOST
RECOGNIZED FOR HIS TENURE AS
THE WHITE HOUSE CHEF. WHO SERVE
THE LAST THREE PRESIDENTS.
WHILE CHEF RUSSIA'S MILITARY
CAREERS WORTHY OF RESPECT WE
ARE HERE TODAY TO HONOR HIS
WORK ON THE ISSUE. OF SUICIDE
PREVENTION. CHEF RUSH HAS
PARTNERED WITH NUMEROUS
ORGANIZATIONS LIKE YOU SO
FISHER HOUSE VFW GOLDSTAR BLUE
STARS RED SKINS. AFTER ALL STAR
KIDS TO SPREAD AWARENESS HE
TRAVELS LITERALLY AROUND THE
WORLD TO MEET WITH THE MEN AND
WOMEN SERVING. AND DOES TWO
THOUSAND. TWO HUNDRED AND
TWENTY TWO PUSH UPS DAILY. ONE
MORE TIME. TWO THOUSAND. TWO
HUNDRED AND TWENTY TWO PUSH OF
DAILY TO KEEP THE ISSUE FRESH
IN HIS MIND CHEF RUSHES
COMMITTED SUICIDE PREVENTION IS
AS STRONG AS HIS BICEPS ARE
BIG. AND TODAY. WE ARE HERE TO
THANK HIM FOR BRINGING LIGHT TO
WHAT IS SURELY A NATIONAL
CRISIS THANK YOU. JEFF ANDRE
RUSH
. MEMBERS. MEMBERS WE HAVE
ADDITIONAL GUESTS THAT HAVE
JOINED US IN THE CHAMBER MISTER
COOLEY YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
MY DS FOR YOUR PRESENTATION.
COLLEAGUES GOOD MORNING IT IS A
PLEASURE TO BE HERE ON THE
FLOOR OF THE ASSEMBLY. AS WE
CONTINUE HONORING OUTSTANDING
SERVICES TO SHOULD OF COURSE WE
HONOR DOTSON LAST WEEK. THE DAY
WE HAVE A PROVISION HONORING
BARBARA RYAN HEART. WHO HAS
WORKED EXCLUSIVELY FOR THE
STATE ASSEMBLY FOR THE LAST
THIRTY EIGHT YEARS. THIS MEANS
THE CHAIN JOINED OUR BODY
PROBABLY WITHIN THE FIRST YEAR
OF WILLIE BROWN'S LONG TENURE
SPEAKER. SHE ACTUALLY STARTED
IN THE POOL BUT VERY QUICKLY
WAS THE SECRETARY OF THE JOINT
RULES COMMITTEE. THIS WAS AN
ENGINEER THIS IS WHERE IN THE
ASSEMBLY MET ON THE LAWNS ON
THE EAST. DURING THE
RESTORATION OF THIS BILL. IT
ALSO MEANS THAT SHE WAS DOING
TO SUPPORT WORK FROM MY FIRST
BOSS LOOP HAPPEN. IN THE JOINT
RULES COMMITTEE WHEN THE- WHEN
THEY'RE RESTORATION OF THE WEST
WING WAS UNDER WAY. THIS
MARVELOUS PEOPLE AS THEY ARRIVE
IN THE BUILDING THEY THEY WALK
AROUND SORT OF GAWKING AT THE
BEAUTY THE BUILDING. SHE WAS
THERE WHEN IT WAS BEING
FINISHED AND THEN THE GREAT
CELEBRATION. ORGANIZED BY THE
JOINT RULES COMMITTEE AS WE
HAVE FIREWORKS AT ALL A WEEK OF
FESTIVITIES. THE FIRST WEEK OF
JANUARY NINETEEN EIGHTY TWO.
FOR STARTERS I SAY THIS IS
SIMPLY STRUCTURAL SERVICES UNIT
IN NINETEEN EIGHTY ONE. AFTER
JOINT RULE SHE SERVED ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SAM FARR AND RICHARD
POLANCO SUPPORT OF THE ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT AND INTERNATIONAL
RELATIONS COMMITTEE. SHE
EVENTUALLY BECAME AN OFFICE
MANAGER FOR THIS SUMMER'S
AUXILIARY SERVICES. WHERE SHE
MANAGED NINE ASSEMBLY SELECT
AND SUBCOMMITTEE OFFICES. WHILE
PROVIDING SUPPORT TO THIRTEEN
COMMITTEE CONSULTANTS. AND THIS
IS ALL WAY BACK IN THE DAY
WITHOUT AUTO CORRECT WITHOUT
SPELL CHECK WITHOUT COMPUTERS.
THOSE DAYS WE HAD IBM SELECTRIC
SWEET WE WERE REALLY ROCK AND
ROLL ORIENTED THAT THAT I'VE
GIVES LIKE WITH THE BALL AND
EVEN A LITTLE BIT OF MEMORY.
SHE WAS DOING ALL THIS WORK AND
CREATING ORIGINAL DOCUMENTS
JUST ON A MANUAL TYPEWRITER.
WITH. COPYING THEM VIA. MEMBER
GRAPH AND CARBON PAPER. AND
SUPPORTING THIS GREAT WORK
INSTITUTION MORE RECENTLY OF
BARBER HAS WORKED AT THE.
DEMOCRATIC ALSO COMMUNICATE
SALARIES DESEO. AND SHE'S GONNA
RESOURCE TO MEMBERS AND
COLLEAGUES THROUGHOUT THE
GREATER LOS A COMMUNITY WITH
HER EXCEPTIONAL BACKGROUND. HER
DAUGHTERS ARE TIED UP IN ROUTE
THEY'RE NOT ACTUALLY HERE TODAY
THEY'RE COMING DOWN I FIVE A
CONTRACTOR BUT WE WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE SHE DID ALL THIS BY
RAISING DANIEL WALKER AND NEED
TO RYAN HARD. SHE'S ALSO JOINED
TODAY BY. SANDRA HILL. CHURCH
PASTOR BISHOP DAVID FOSTER IN
THE BACK AND TAKING PICTURES
RIGHT NOW. IRENE JOHNSON AND
HER CELL TEASDALE. SO FAR ON
BEHALF OF THE SPEAKER. LUCIEN.
THANK YOU FOR THIRTY EIGHT
YEARS OF SERVICE TO THIS BODY
.
MEMBERS WE HAVE ADDITIONAL
GUEST WITH US TODAY MEMBERS.
MISTER KALRA HAS A VERY SPECIAL
GUEST ON THE FLOOR TODAY MISTER
KALRA. THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS IT'S MY HONOR TO
INTRODUCE ON THE FLOOR TODAY'S
BEEN ON THE FOR A COUPLE TIMES
A FOR THE LAST COUPLE YEARS
DOCTOR SET THE APOLLO KALRA MY
FATHER. SET THE KALRA. IS
SOMEONE THAT WAS BORN PRIOR TO
THE INDIAN PARTITION AND AS A
SMALL CHILD HAD TO FLEE. WITH
HIS FAMILY IN THE LARGEST
MOVEMENT OF HUMAN BEINGS IN
THAT SHORT PERIOD OF TIME IN
THE HISTORY OF THE WORLD.
ESTIMATED ANYWHERE FROM ONE TO
TWO MILLION PEOPLE DIED DURING
THAT PROCESS AND SO WE ALL FEEL
VERY LUCKY THAT. HE AND HIS
FAMILY WERE ABLE TO ESCAPE THAT
THE CHAOS OF THAT TIME THERE WE
SETTLED AS REFUGEES IN A SMALL
TOWN CALLED SON BELA THAT DID
NOT HAVE ELECTRICITY. AND
THAT'S WHERE HE GREW UP FOR
MANY OF THESE YEARS. I WOULD GO
TO SCHOOL IN THE. A ONE
BUILDING SCHOOL WHERE THEY
WOULD TYPICALLY HAVE THEIR
CLASSES OUTDOORS. AND IT WASN'T
UNTIL HIGH SCHOOL THEY MOVED TO
A BIGGER CITY LUCK NOW. BUT
EVEN THEN WOULD STAY UP LATE
RESTARTING BY KEROSENE LAMP. AS
HE HAD A PASSION FOR LEARNING
AND FOR EDUCATION. THAT PASSION
ALLOWED I'M ULTIMATELY FROM
VERY HUMBLE BEGINNINGS TO DO
SOMETHING THAT. WAS VERY
UNUSUAL THE TIME FOR SOMEONE
GOING TO A WORKING CLASS PUBLIC
SCHOOL. HE EVENTUALLY NOT ONLY
GOT IS BACHELOR'S DEGREES AT
BATCHES GRAHAM MULTIPLE MASTERS
DEGREES BUT EVENTUALLY GOT A
SCHOLARSHIP TO UNIVERSITY OF
TORONTO. I GOT HIS PHD IN
AERONAUTICS SO HE'S LITERALLY A
ROCKET SCIENTIST. AND WITH THAT
KIND OF PRESSURE YOU KNOW WHY
WHY I WENT TO LAW SCHOOL. AND
ULTIMATELY BE SETTLED IN SAN
JOSE WHERE I GREW UP. AND IS
SOMEONE THAT HAS SUPPORTED ME
AND- MY BROTHER MY FAMILY'S OUT
SHE WAS ALSO MY FAMILY'S OTHER
HERE'S ANOTHER HERE. HE DOES
NOW IT'S OF ALWAYS SUPPORTED MY
BROTHER AND I AND EVERYTHING
THAT WE'VE DONE. AND NOT ONLY.
DID HE GIVE ME OPPORTUNITY AND
WHAT HE DID WASN'T JUST
EXTRAORDINARY FOR HIMSELF AS A
HUMAN BEING AS ONE INDIVIDUAL
BUT AS WE KNOW PARTICULARLY
WHEN IT COMES. TO THE IMMIGRANT
STORY HE IS LITERALLY CHANGE
THE TRAJECTORY OF OUR FAMILY
FOR GENERATIONS TO COME.
BECAUSE OF THE WORK THAT HE PUT
IN TO MAKE HIMSELF BETTER AND
SACRIFICING EVERYTHING FOR HIS
FAMILY. AND SO HE'S SOMEONE
THAT NOT ONLY WE SHOULD ALL BE
PROUD TO CALL CALIFORNIAN. BUT
SOMEONE THAT I'M PROUD OF AND
I'M VERY PROUD TO CALL MYSELF
HIS SON. BECAUSE OF EVERYTHING.
THAT HE'S DONE AND EVERYTHING
HE. HAS ALLOWED ME AND MY
BROTHER TO DO IN ORDER TO BUILD
A LIFE HERE AND NOT JUST MY
BROTHER AND I WE HAVE MY
COUSINS AND SO MANY OTHER
FAMILY MEMBERS ARE ABLE TO COME
HERE. BECAUSE OF ONE MAN'S
JOURNEY. AND SO I JUST WANT TO
WISH YOU A VERY HAPPY SEVENTY
FIFTH BIRTHDAY TODAY. AND HOPE
YOU CAN ALL JOIN ME IN
WELCOMING THEM TO THE STATE
ASSEMBLY
. I MEMBERS PLEASE GIVE
YOUR ATTENTION TO MISTER
GALLAGHER MISTER GALLAGHER HAS
SPECIAL GUESTS IN THE GALLERY
TODAY MISS GALLAGHER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS AND IT IS MY
DISTINCT HONOR AND WOULD YOU
PLEASE WELCOME WITH ME THE LADY
SPARTANS FROM IS NICOLAS HIGH
SCHOOL SOFTBALL TEAM. UP IN THE
GALLERY. ONE MAY TWENTIETH TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN THESE THE
BECAUSE HIGH SCHOOL SPARTANS
TEAM DEFEATED THE AT THE HIGH
SCHOOL LINES BY A SCORE OF TEN
TO ZERO. IN THE C. I. F.
NORTHERN SECTION CHAMPIONSHIP
GAME IN TROWBRIDGE CALIFORNIA
EARNING A THIRTY TWO IN TWO
SPARTANS THEIR SECOND
CONSECUTIVE AND THIRD AND
FOURTH. IN FOUR YEARS SECTION
CHAMPIONSHIP AND THEIR SECOND
TIME BEING RECOGNIZED AS THE
NUMBER ONE SOFTBALL TEAM IN
DIVISION FIVE IN THE STATE.
THIS IS THEIR SECOND THIRTY WIN
SEASON. AND THE SPARTANS PLAYED
UP THIS YEAR DEFEATING FOR
DIFFERENT SECTION CHAMPIONSHIP
TEAMS FROM THE C. I. F. NORTH
COAST NORTHERN IN SAN JOAQUIN
SECTIONS. AS WELL AS FINISHED
WITH THE NINETEEN TO INTO
RECORD AGAINST SO MUCH LARGER
SCHOOLS AS A TEAM THE SPARTANS
ALLOWED TWENTY SIX RUNS AND
SEVENTY SEVEN HITS IN THIRTY
FOUR GAMES WHILE SCORING THREE
HUNDRED AND THIRTY SIX. RUNS IN
AMASSING THREE HUNDRED FIFTY
ONE TEAM HITS THEIR
EXTRAORDINARY TEAM LED BY THEIR
COACH NEIL STINSON WHO IS WITH
THEM HERE TODAY AND WE JUST
WANT TO RECOGNIZE THEIR GREAT
ACHIEVEMENTS IN ALL OF THE
STAFF ADMINISTRATION COACHES
TEACHERS STUDENTS PARENTS AND
FRIENDS I KNOW WHO ARE HERE
TODAY. TO COMMEND THEM ON THEIR
EXEMPLARY ACHIEVEMENTS. AN
AWESOME SEASON THIS YEAR THANK
YOU GUYS FOR BEING HERE
.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO MOVE TO
BUSINESS ON THE DAILY FILE.
SECOND READING CLICK RATE SOME
PEOPLE SIXTEEN THIRTY NINE
SENATE BILL. FIVE SIX EIGHT TEN
NINETEEN TWENTY TWO TWENTY FOUR
FORTY FORTY FOUR FORTY NINE
FIFT TO TWO OO
521-126-2762 828-929-4290
630-231-3320 EIGHT. THREE
TWENTY NINE THREE THIRTY THREE
FORTY NINE THREE FIFTY ONE.
FIFTY FOUR THREE SIXTY THREE
THREE SIXTY SEVEN THREE SEVENTY
FIVE THREE SEVENTY SIX  THREE NINETY FIVE FOUR
OH SEVEN FOUR SIXTEEN FOR
TWENTY FIVE FOR TWENTY EIGHT.
494-409-4554 FIFTY NINE. FOUR
EIGHTY SEVEN FIVE OH FOUR FIVE
THIRTEEN FIVE EIGHTEEN FIVE
NINETEEN FIVE TWENTY 435-402-5545 FIFTY
EIGHT. FIVE SEVENTY FIVE FIVE
SEVENTY SIX FIVE EIGHTY THREE
FIVE EIGHTY EIGHT SIX HUNDRED
S 1-661-162-6226
263-361-6860 FIVE SIX NINETY.
SEVEN NINETY ONE. THE FOLLOWING
SENATE BILLS ARE WITH MOMENTS.
SENATE BILL. ONE SEVEN THIRTEEN
SEVENTEEN TWENTY NINE THIRTY
FOUR THIRTY FIVE FORTY TO.
FIFTY EIGHT SIXTY ONE SIXTY
THREE SIXTY EIGHT ONE TWENTY
SEVEN ONE THIRTY TO ONE THI 381-391-4021. 515-916-1631
SEVENTY TWO ONE SEVENTY SIX ONE
EIGHTY. ONE EIGHTY FOUR. NINETY
SIX TO A 629-210-2182 TWENTY
EIGHT TO THIRTY TO FORTY SEVEN
TO FIFTY FIVE. TO SIXTY TWO TO
SIXTY FIVE TO SIXTY SIX TO
SIXTY EIGHT TO SIXTY NINE. TO
SEVENTY THREE TO SEVENTY SEVEN
THREE SEVENTEEN THREE THIRTY
SEVEN THREE FORTY FOU FOR FORTY TWO
FOUR FIFTY ONE FOR FIFTY THREE
FOUR SIXTY THREE FOUR SIXTY
FOUR FOUR S FOUR NINETY
FIVE A THREE FIVE TWENTY FIVE
THIRTY FIVE THIRTY SEVEN FIVE
FORTY ONE. BY. FIFTY ONE FIVE
EIGHTY ONE FIVE EIGHTY NINE
FIVE NINETY FIVE SIX FORTY
SEVEN SIX SEV SEVEN
EIGHTY FIVE. THANK YOU KATHLEEN.
ALL BILL SEVENTY READ AND
AMENDMENTS DEEMED ADOPTED
.
MISTER CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR PROCEDURAL
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
WITHDRAW AB SEVENTY FIVE BLOOM
FROM THE GOVERNOR'S DESK AND
RETURN THE BILL TO THE SENATE
FOR FURTHER ACTION. WITHOUT
OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE THE
ORDER. MEMBERS WE ARE ON
CONCURRENCE FILE. BUT ITEM FILE
ITEM IS ONE FIFTY EIGHT AND ONE
FIFTY NINE PASS AND RETAIN FILE
ITEM ONE SIXTY. THIS IS MISS
WICKS AB THIRTEEN FIFTY THREE.
CORPORATION ASSEMBLY BILL
THIRTEEN FIFTY THREE BY SOME
THE MEMBER WICKS AND ACTUALLY
THE SCHOOL EMPLOYEES MISS WICKS
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS AB THIRTEEN FIFTY THREE
BRINGS CONFORMITY AND CLARITY
FOR K. TWELVE CLASSIFIED STAFF
BY ALLOWING FOR CLASSIFIED
EMPLOYEES AND NON MERIT
DISTRICTS TO OBTAIN PERMANENT
STATUS NO LATER THAN SIX MONTHS
SENATE AMENDMENTS WERE
TECHNICAL AND CLARIFYING. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
NAME IS WICKS SEEN NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE ITEM.
CAR CLUB IN THE ROLE MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE ON MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF EL. ALL MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE. CLICK
WELL. CLOSER ALL THE TIME BUT
ICE FORTY SEVEN KNOWS TWELVE.
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN. THIS IS FILE ITEM ONE SIXTY
ONE AB FORTY SEVEN CLICK RATE
ASSEMBLY BILL FORTY SEVEN BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER DALY AND
ACTUALLY THE DRIVER'S LICENSES
MR DAILY THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS SENATE
AMENDMENTS DELAY IMPLEMENTATION
OF THIS BILL UNTIL JULY FIRST
OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE. AND MAKE
CLARIFYING CHANGES THE BILL HAS
SUPPORT ON BOTH SIDES AND I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISS DALY
SAYING NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON
THE ITEM CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE. OTHERS ARE LOW ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE. THE DESIRE TO
VOTE. CLARK WELL. ROLL TIDE OF
AN ICE FIFTY SEVEN NO ZERO
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN FILE ITEM ONE SIXTY TWO A.
B. TWO SIX THREE CLERK READ AT
SOME LEVEL TO SIXTY THREE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BURKE AND
ACTUALLY TAXATION. IS BURKE A
GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS AB TWO
SIXTY THREE IS BACK ON CAN
CURRENT SENTIMENTS ARE
TECHNICAL IN NATURE AND ENSURE
THE SECTION FORTY ONE
REQUIREMENTS APPLY TO SALES.
AND USE TAX LAW AB TWO SIXTY
THREE ENJOYS A STRONG
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT THE SUPPORT
OF THE CALIFORNIA TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA STATE
PTA AND THE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
ADMINISTRATORS. I REQUEST AND I
WILL. THING IS BURKE SEEN NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE. CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE. OF THE DESIRE TO
VOTE ON MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS OF THE DESIRE
TO VOTE. CLICK WELL CLOSER ROLL
TIDE ABOUT EYES FIFTY SEVEN NO
ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN PASS RETAIN A FILE
ON ONE SIXTY THREE ONE SIXTY
FOUR IS A. B. SIX NINE SEVEN
CORPORATION ASSEMBLY BILL SIX
NINETY SEVEN BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
TING AND OTHERS AND ACTUALLY A
POST SECONDARY EDUCATION. MR
TING EMAIL BUT THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AB SIX NINE SEVEN IS
BACK ON CONCURRENCE SENATE
AMENDMENTS CHANGE THE BILL FOR
THE UNIVERSITIES AND COLLEGES.
ARE ONLY ASKED TO REPORT THE
INFORMATION REGARDING DONORS
AND ADMISSIONS VOLUNTARILY
THERE IS NO OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL WE RECEIVE BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT IN THE SENATE AND
RESPECTFULLY ASKS. FOR YOUR AYE
BOATING CONCURRENCE IN SENATE
AMENDMENTS. THANK YOU MISTER
TANKS SEEING NO DISCUSSION
DEBATE CLERK LIBERAL. DESIRE
VOTE ON MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE
DESIRE TO VOTE. CLARK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT ICE FIFTY
FOUR KNOWS ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN
HOUSE RETAIN A FILE ITEMS ONE
SIXTY FIVE. AND ONE SIXTY SIX.
FILE ITEM ONE SIXTY SEVEN S. A.
B. NINE TWENTY THREE CORKERY
ASSEMBLY BILL NINE TWENTY THREE
BY SOMETHING MEMBER WICKS AND
ACTUALLY TOOK TRICITY. MISS
WICKS YOU MAY GET OPEN THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS AB
NINE TWENTY THREE WOULD ALLOW
BAY AREA RAPID TRANSIT OR THE
PART TO ACCESS THE CALIFORNIA
INDEPENDENT SYSTEMS OPERATOR
WHOLESALE MARKET. SENATE
AMENDMENTS STATE THE
LEGISLATURE'S INTENT TO
PROHIBIT BARK FROM BECOMING A
RETAIL SELLER OR ENERGY ENERGY
MARKETER AND REQUIRE BAR TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE POWER SOURCE
DISCLOSED PROGRAM. THIS BILL
HAS RECEIVED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
AND HAS NO STATE COSTS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE FOR CONCURRENCE AND
SENTIMENTS. FAMOUS WICKS SEEN
NO DISCUSSION DEBATE. OR CLUB
IN THE WRONG. NUMBER SO. THE
SAD ABOUT ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
ARE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTER
DESIRE TO VOTE. CLARK WELL
CLOSER ALL TELL ABOUT AYE AYES
FIFTY NINE NO ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
FILE ITEM ONE SIXTY EIGHT. IS
AB NINE FORTY EIGHT HI MISTER
KALRA. THE CLERK WILL READ AS
UNABLE NINE FORTY EIGHT BY
SOMETHING MEMBER KALRA AND
OTHERS AND I PLAYED A COYOTE
VALLEY CONSERVATION PROGRAM.
MISTER KALRA YOU MAIL. THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS SOME
OF THE MEMBERS TO ASSEMBLY BILL
NINE FORTY EIGHT REFINED THE
DEFINITION A COYOTE VALLEY AND
REMOVE THE PENALTY DISTRIBUTION
PROVISION IN THE BILL TO
RESOLVE CONCERNS FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND WILDLIFE
EIGHTY NINE FOUR FORTY EIGHT
WHICH IS WHICH A HAS BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT PASS OUT OF THE SENATE
LAST WEEK WITH NO REGISTERED
OPPOSITION I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE ON THE AMENDMENTS.
THERE IS KALRA SEE NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE. COUPLE OF
OTHER ALL ALL MEMBERS LETTERS
OUT OF ALL MEMBERS OF A DESIRE
TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS OTHERS ARE
VOTE. CLERK WILL CLOSE ROLL
TIDE BUT I SIXTY SIX NO ZERO
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN FILE ITEM ONE SIXTY NINE AND
ONE SEVENTY PASS RETAIN. FILE
ITEM ONE SEVENTY ONE. IS AB
THIRTEEN ELEVEN MR TANKER
CARILLO ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTEEN
ELEVEN BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER TING
AND OTHERS AND ACT LIKE
ALCOHOLIC BEVERAGES MR TING
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER A. B.
THIRTEEN ELEVEN IS A DISTRICT
BILL I ITS BACK FROM SENATE-TV
FROM THE CENTER FOR CONCURRENCE
CONFORMING AMENDMENTS WERE MADE
TO RESOLVE CONFLICTS WITH SB
EIGHTY TO A BUDGET TRAILER BILL
THIS DISTRICT BILL REVISES AN
EXISTING PROGRAM IN SAN
FRANCISCO CREATING A SMALL
AMOUNT OF FLEXIBILITY FOR SMALL
BUSINESS OWNERS WHO ARE
UNFAIRLY SUBJECT TO READ
INCREASES. IN MAY RUN THE RISK
OF LOSING THEIR TYPE EIGHTY
SEVEN LIQUOR LICENSE SO WITH
THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK RIGHT.
THINGS CHANGE S. C. NOTICE
SESSION REMAIN ON THE ADAM
CORPORAL OF THE ROLE. ALL
MEMBERS OF DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS OF A DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE CLICK WELL CLOSER ROLE
TALLY THE VOTE EYES SIXTY EIGHT
NO ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. FILE ITEM ONE
SEVENTY TWO A. B. FOURTEEN
TWENTY THREE CORPORATE ASSEMBLY
BILL FOURTEEN TWENTY THREE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WICKS AND
ACTUALLY DID YOU CAN ALSO. THIS
WORKS THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
AB FOURTEEN TWENTY THREE
ESTABLISHES A NARROWLY TECH
TAILORED PROCESS FOR JUVENILES
TO REQUEST THE CRIMINAL COURT
TO TRANSFER CASE TO JUVENILE
COURT IN A LIMITED NUMBER OF
SITUATIONS. SENATE AMENDMENTS
REMOVE ALL OPPOSITION THIS BILL
HAS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. DAVIS WICKS SEE NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE. APPLE OF THE
ROLE. OF THE CEREMONY. ALL
MEMBERS OF A DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OF THE DESIRE TO
VOTE. CLERK WILL CLOSE ROLL
TIDE ABOUT AYE SIXTY ONE NO
ZERO SENTIMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN FILE ITEMS ONE SEVENTY THREE
THROUGH ONE SEVENTY FIVE. S.
RETAIN WORD FILE ITEM ONE
SEVENTY SIX HA ARE FOURTEEN.
SENATE AMENDMENTS HONORE FOR
JOHNSON WHO FOUNDED SPECIAL
OLYMPICS CALIFORNIA BRINGS
ATTENTION TO THE MANY YEAR
ROUND ACTIVITIES THAT INCLUDE
OVER SIXTY FIVE THOUSAND
ATHLETES AND PARTNERS. SINCE
NINETEEN SIXTY EIGHT SPECIAL
EPICS OF HIGHLIGHTED WHAT
ATHLETES CAN ACCOMPLISH INSTEAD
OF WHAT THEY CANNOT. IT FOCUSES
ON HOW OUR DIFFERENCES BRING US
TOGETHER RATHER THAN DIVIDING
US. SPECIAL EFFECTS DOES FAR
MORE THAN JUST REFINED PHYSICAL
SKILLS. IT HAS BEEN PROVEN TO
AID THE MENTAL AND EMOTIONAL
WELL BEING OF HE ATHLETES.
WELL FACILITATING NEW
SOCIALIZATION OPPORTUNITIES AND
EDUCATIONAL EQUITY. ALSO
CREATING A BASS BENEFIT TO
BEHAVIOR IT HAS BEEN MY
PRIVILEGE AND HONOR TO ADVOCATE
FOR THE ID DE COMMUNITY.
MEMBERS PLEASE JOIN ME IN
RECOGNIZING SPECIAL EPICS AS A
FUNDAMENTAL ORGANIZATION FOR
INDIVIDUALS WITH DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES AND I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR SUPPORT FOR THIS
MEASURE THANK YOU. THANK
INITIAL LACKEY. SEE NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE CLUB CLUB THE
ROLE. NUMBER SEVEN ZERO ALL
MEMBERS OF. DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLARK WELL CLOSER ROLL TIDE
ABOUT I SIX NINE NEWS ZERO
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN. FILE ITEM ONE SEVENTY SEVEN
PASS RETAIN. ON RECONSIDERATION
FILE ITEMS ONE EIGHTY TWO
THROUGH ONE EIGHTY FIVE OR TO
BE CONTINUED THAT BRINGS US TO
THE ASSEMBLY THIRD READING FILE
PASS RETAIN ON FILE ITEM. ONE
EIGHTY SIX THROUGH. FILE ITEM
ONE NINETY. WE'RE AT FILE ITEM
ONE NINETY ONE. AJ ARE SEVEN
CLICK RATE AS ON THE JOINT
RESOLUTION SEVEN BY SOMETHING
MEMBER GLORIA AND OTHERS
RELATIVE TO THE GREEN NEW DEAL.
MISTER GLORIA. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I RISE THIS AFTERNOON
TO PRESENT AJ ARE SEVEN WHICH
URGES THE UNITED STATES
CONGRESS TO PURSUE POLICIES
UNDER THE GREEN NEW DEAL THAT
BUILT ON CALIFORNIA'S OWN
TREMENDOUS CLIMATE ACTION.
CURRENTLY THE GREEN NEW DEAL IS
A CLIMATE FRAMEWORK IS IGNITED
DISCUSSION IN ACTIVISM ACROSS
OUR COUNTRY. AS CORD ASK THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO TREAT
CLIMATE CHANGE LIKE THE
NATIONAL EMERGENCY THAT IT IS.
ENVISIONED THE DEVELOPMENT OF
INNOVATIVE POLICIES AND
PROGRAMS CAPABLE OF LOWERING
EMISSIONS AND IMPROVING PUBLIC
HEALTH WHILE CREATING TRUST
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT. IN
CALIFORNIA WE HAVE LONG
UNDERSTOOD THE URGENCY OF
ACTING ON CLIMATE CHANGE AND
THIS BODY THIS ASSEMBLY HAS
RESPONDED BY ACTING
GROUNDBREAKING CLIMATE POLICIES
THAT ARE NOW BEING EMULATED
ACROSS THE NATION AND AROUND
THE WORLD. BUT WE KNOW WE
CANNOT DO THIS ALL ALONE TO
ACHIEVE GLOBAL CLIMATE CHANGE
TARGETS WE NEED THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT TO TAKE THIS THREAT
SERIOUSLY AND MOBILIZE
ACCORDINGLY. THIS TYPE OF
ACTION IS BY NO MEANS
UNPRECEDENTED IN OUR NATION'S
HISTORY WHICH COMBAT FASCISM BY
TRANSFORMING ITS ECONOMY AS
WELL AS TACKLING UNPRECEDENTED
UNEMPLOYMENT DURING THE GREAT
RECESSION. AS ARE DISCUSSED AS
OUR DISCUSSION CONTINUES AT THE
FEDERAL LEVEL PARTICIPANTS WILL
LOOK TO CALIFORNIA FOR BOTH
GUIDANCE AND ENCOURAGEMENT. AJ
ARE SEVEN PROVIDES THIS
FOUNDATION WHILE ALSO PUSHING
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO TRULY
PARTNER WITH STATES LIKE
CALIFORNIA TO PURSUE ACTIONABLE.
CLIMATE ACTION I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE THOSE. THANK
YOU MISS GLORIA. SEEING NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
RESOLUTION MR GLORIA WOULD YOU
LIKE CO AUTHORS. MR WAR IS
ASKING THAT THE FIRST ROLE BE
OPEN FOR CO AUTHORS CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE. NUMBERS THIS IS
FOR CO AUTHORS ON THE AJ ARE.
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS ON THE
RESOLUTION. THE. THE CLICK WELL.
CLOSER ALL THEIR FORTY FOUR CO
AUTHORS ADDED THIS IS AN H. A
R. THEREFORE WE WILL TAKE A
ROLL CALL VOTE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS OTHERS
ARE DEVOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTER
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED IS OUT OF A. CLICK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT AYE AYES
FORTY SEVEN THOSE FOURTEEN THE
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED. PASS
RETAIN A FILE ITEMS ONE NINETY
TWO AND ONE NINETY THREE. THIS
IS FILE ITEM ONE NINETY FOUR.
H. A R. TWENTY ONE BY MS
GONZALEZ CLERK WILL READ
ASSEMBLY JOINT RESOLUTION
TWENTY ONE BY SOMETHING MEMBER
GONZALEZ AND OTHERS RELATIVE TO
REPARATIONS FOR DESCENDENTS OF
ENSLAVED PERSONS. GONZALEZ
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I LAST
WEEK MY COLLEAGUE FROM SAN
DIEGO PRESENTED A RESOLUTION IN
DEPTH ABOUT WHY WE NEED TO
ADDRESS REPARATIONS HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. THIS IS IN LINE
WITHOUT BUT A LITTLE JUST JUST.
PRETTY SPECIFIC AGE YOU ARE
TWENTY ONE ONE WOULD DECLARE
CALIFORNIA SUPPORT FOR HR FORTY
THAT'S THE FEDERAL LEGISLATION
THAT WOULD ESTABLISH A
COMMISSION TO STUDY IN DEVELOP
PROPOSALS FOR REPARATIONS TO
DESCENDANTS OF ENSLAVED PERSONS
THE UNITED STATES. THIS
RESOLUTION ALSO FORMALLY
APOLOGIZE FOR THE LEGISLATURE'S
COMPLICITY IN FURTHERING THE
PRACTICE OF SLAVERY OF ALL
PEOPLE IN CALIFORNIA. TO BE
CLEAR NEITHER THIS RESOLUTION
NOR HR FORTY ENDORSES ANYONE
FORM OF REPARATIONS BUT RATHER
LEAVE THAT TO A COMMISSION TO
EXPERTS TO STUDY POSSIBLE
AVENUES OUR COUNTRY CANNOT
BEGIN TO ADDRESS INCREDIBLE
RATE WELL IN EQUITIES PREVALENT
IN OUR SOCIETY INTO WEEK SEPT.
WORKS WHAT REDRESS OF OUR
COUNTRY'S ORIGINAL SIN AND IT'S
TIME THAT OUR STATE
ACKNOWLEDGES OUR ROLE IN IT AS
WELL I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MS GONZALEZ.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON
THE H. A R. MRS ALSO WOULD YOU
LIKE CO AUTHORS ON THE
RESOLUTION PERSONAL BE OPEN FOR
CO AUTHORS CORE GLOBAL ROLE.
EVER SINCE FOR CO AUTHORS. ON
THE RESOLUTION THIS IS FOR CO
AUTHORS. AS FOR CO AUTHORS ON A
CHAIR TWENTY ONE. CLERK WILL
CLOSER ALL THERE ARE FIFTY
THREE CO AUTHORS ADDED THIS IS
A MAJOR ARE WILL TAKE A ROLL
CALL VOTE. PAR CLUBIC. THE
CEREMONY ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE
TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS OTHERS ARE
TO VOTE. CLARK WELL CULTURAL
TIES THE VOTE EYES FIFTY FOUR
KNOWS FOR THE RESOLUTION IS
ADOPTED
. MEMBERS WE ARE ON
ASSEMBLY THIRD READING FILE%
THIS IS FILE ITEM ONE NINETY
FIVE H. A R. TWENTY TWO BY MR
TANG COVERAGE IS ON THE JOINT
RESOLUTION TWENTY TO BUY
SOMETHING MEMBER TING AND
OTHERS RELATIVE TO THE SEVENTY
SIXTH ANNIVERSARY OF THE REPEAL
OF THE CHINESE EXCLUSION ACT.
SURE CHIANG EMAIL. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AG ARE TWENTY TO
RECOGNIZE THE DECEMBER
SEVENTEENTH TWENTY NINETEEN AS
A SEVENTY SIXTH ANNIVERSARY OF
THE REPEAL OF THE CHINESE
EXCLUSION ACT IT ALSO CALLS
UPON THE PRESIDENT TO RESCIND
HIS ANTI IMMIGRANT AND ANTI
MUSLIM EXECUTIVE ORDERS AS
YOU'RE ALL AWARE THE CHINESE
EXCLUSION ACT WAS THE COUNTRY'S
FIRST LAW PROHIBITING
IMMIGRATION SOLELY ON THE BASIS
OF THE NECESSITY. TO PREVENT A
CHINESE LABORERS FROM THE TO
THE COUNTRY DESPITE THE MANY
YEARS THAT THESE LABORS HAVE
WORKED ON THE TRANSCONTINENTAL
RAILROAD MAKING THAT CONNECTION
BETWEEN EAST AND WEST COAST A
POSSIBILITY UNFORTUNATELY
HISTORY SEEMS TO BE REPEATING
ITSELF IN OUR TIMES TODAY HAVE
VERY ANGRY RHETORIC YOUR
TOWARDS IMMIGRANTS AS WELL AS
PEOPLE OF DIFFERENT FAITHS I
THINK IT'S A CONSTANT REMINDER
THAT WE NEED TO BE VIGILANT AND
REMAINING OPEN TO MAKING SURE
THAT WE ARE WELCOMING PEOPLE.
FROM NOT JUST AROUND THE
COUNTRY BUT REALLY FROM AROUND
THE. WORLD AND WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASTEROID VOTE ON
AGING. THANK YOU MISTER TANG
WOULD YOU LIKE CO AUTHORS ON.
THIS MEASURES AND YES PLEASE ON
ASSEMBLY THIRD READING. THANK
YOU. MEMBERS THE CLERK LIBERAL
FOR COOPERATION RESOLUTION THIS
IS FOR CO AUTHORS. THIS IS FOR
CO AUTHORS. THE CLERK WILL
CLOSE RATHER FIFTY ONE CO
AUTHORS ADDED WE WILL TAKE A
ROLL CALL VOTE ON AG ARE TWENTY
TWO CAR CLUB IN THE ROLE. THE
DESIRE TO VOTE ON MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE DESIRABLE. CLICK WELL.
CLOSER ALL TIED ABOUT ICE FIFTY
TWO KNOWS THREE THAT RESOLUTION
IS ADOPTED PASS RETAIN A FILE
AND ONE NINETY SIX THAT BRINGS
US TO THE SENATE THIRD READING
FILE. FILE ITEMS ONE NINETY
SEVEN THROUGH TO A ONE. PASS
AND RETAIN. THIS IS FILE ITEM
TWO OH TWO SB TWO EIGHTY FOUR.
CORPORATION SENATE BILL TWO
EIGHTY FOUR BY SENATOR BELL AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY TO DO THAT
ALSO. DOCTOR WEBER. YES GOOD
MORNING MISS OF GOOD AFTERNOON
MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I
RISE TODAY ON BEHALF OF SENATOR
BAIL. WE KNOW IS AN ADVOCATE
FOR MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES AND
SOCIAL JUSTICE ISSUES FOR YOUNG
PEOPLE TO PRESENT TO YOU SB TWO
EIGHTY FOUR. THE KEEP YOUTH
CLOSE TO HOME ACT. THE ANNUAL
COST TO CONFINE YOUTH AT THE
DIVISION OF JUVENILE JUSTICE
AVERAGES MORE THAN THREE
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS PER
YOUTH. OF THAT AMOUNT COUNTIES
CONTRIBUTE ONLY 8% OF THE
TWENTY FOUR THOUSAND PER YOUTH
WAS STATE WITH THE STATE PAYING
THE REST AND TAXPAYERS
SUBSIDIZING THE COST. SB TWO
EIGHTY FOUR INCREASES THE
COUNTY THREE TWO HUNDRED AND
TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS
FOR MORE FOR MANY YOUTH TO SPUR
LOCAL REHABILITATION COMMUNITY
BASED SUPPORT AND KEEP THEM
CLOSE TO HOME. WE HAVE SEEN A
SIGNIFICANT DECLINE IN D. JJ'S
POPULATION OVER THE LAST
DECADE. WELL WE HAD NEARLY TEN
THOUSAND YOUNG PEOPLE IN DJJ.
WE ROUGHLY NOW ONLY HAVE SEVEN
HUNDRED. HOWEVER THE DECLINE IS
DUE TO THE STEADY REDUCTION IN
YOUTH CRIME AND CHANGES THAT WE
HAVE MADE TO PROMOTE
ALTERNATIVES TO INCARCERATION.
WE NEED TO CONTINUE MAKING
THESE CHANGES FOR OUR YOUTH AND
INVEST IN COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS AND LOCAL
ALTERNATIVES. CONFINEMENT AT A
YOUTH PRISON IS DETRIMENTAL TO
ONE'S MENTAL HEALTH AND FOR
YOUTH ESPECIALLY CAN IT
SIGNIFICANTLY INCREASE TRAUMA.
THE YOUTH MOST
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED BY
INCARCERATION OR COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR AND LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES. REHABILITATION
CREATES CHANGE NOT
INCARCERATION. STUDIES SHOW
YOUTH ARE EXTREMELY VULNERABLE
AS THEY MOVE FROM ADOLESCENCE
TO ADULTHOOD AND HOW WE CARE
FOR THEM DOING THESE YEARS WILL
SHAPE THEIR FUTURE. THE
GOVERNOR AGREES THAT THE
CORRECT THE FACILITIES ARE NOT
APPROPRIATE ENVIRONMENTS TO
ADDRESS YOUTH UNDERLYING NEEDS.
THAT IS WHY WE PROPOSED TO SHIP
DJJ FROM CDC ARE THE HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES BECAUSE YOUTH
NEED SOCIAL WORKERS NOT
CORRECTIONAL OFFICERS. IF WE
LOOK AT THE J. J.'S MOST RECENT
DATA FROM TWENTY TWELVE WE SEE
THAT 74% OF YOU THROUGH A SET
OF EIGHT WITHIN THREE YEARS OF
RELEASE. IN ORDER TO CHANGE
THOSE NUMBERS AND ENSURE
SUCCESS UPON RELEASE. YOUTH
NEED EFFECTIVE REHABILITATION
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATION
INVOLVEMENT AND CLOSE REGULAR
CONTACT WITH LOVED ONES AND
SUPPORT SYSTEMS. SB TWO EIGHTY
FOUR CREATES A FISCAL
INCENTIVES FOR COUNTIES TO
CRITICALLY CONSIDER ALL VIABLE
OPTIONS RATHER THAN DJJ FIRST.
SUCH AS CONTRACTED WITH OTHER
COUNTIES FOR THOSE WHO DO NOT
SECURE HAVE SECURE FACILITIES
WITHOUT STATE ACTION SOME
COUNTIES WILL CONTINUE TO RELY
HEAVILY ON THE STATE SYSTEM AS
A SAFETY NET. DESPITE OPERATING
SECURE LOCAL FACILITIES THAT
ARE MORE THAN 70% EMPTY. WE
EXPECT SB SB TWO EIGHTY FOUR TO
INCREASE STATE REVENUE AND
BOOZE COST SAVINGS BY TENS OF
MILLIONS WITH POTENTIAL FUTURE
BENEFITS TO THE STATE'S BOTTOM
LINE IN THE HIGH TENS OF
MILLIONS. THE BILL THE BILL
AIMS TO PROMOTE LOCAL
REHABILITATION CREATE
SUPPORTIVE AND SAFE
ENVIRONMENTS AND REDUCE OF IT
IT REALLY WAS SAID OF ISM. WE
HAVE AN OBLIGATION TO MAKE
DECISIONS THAT PROMOTE THE
SUCCESS AND WELL BEING OF THE
PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA THAT IS
WHY THE LEGISLATURE CONTINUES
TO INVEST IN COMMUNITY
ORGANIZATIONS AND LOCAL
TREATMENT. MEMBERS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT. BEHALF OF OUR CHILDREN
IN CALIFORNIA. WOULD VOTED FOR
SB TO BEFORE. THE DESIRE TO
VOTE. CLICK WELL. CLOSE ROLL
TIDE ABOUT AYE AYES FORTY FIVE
KNOWS FIFTEEN THAT MEASURE
PASSES PASS RETAIN A FILE IN
TWO OR THREE. FILE ITEM TO FOR.
SB FOUR SIXTY SEVEN CORPOREAL
SAMPLE FOR SIXTY SEVEN BY
SENATOR MONNING AND OTHERS AND
ACTUALLY TO POST SECONDARY
EDUCATION MISTER CUNNINGHAM YOU
MAY OPEN THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS SP FOUR SIXTY
SEVEN AS THE COLLEGE COSTS
TRANSPARENCY BILL. THE CSU IN
UC SYSTEM SHOULD PROVIDE
PROSPECTIVE STUDENTS WITH
ACCURATE INFORMATION ABOUT THE
TRUE AND TOTAL COST OF
ATTENDING THEIR SCHOOLS
INCLUDING THE AVERAGE COST OF
HOUSING. THIS BILL WOULD HAVE
THEM DO THAT AND ARM
PERSPECTIVE STUDENTS WITH
INFORMATION TO MAKE AN INFORMED
DECISION ABOUT WHERE TO ATTEND
SCHOOL. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
NINE VOTE. THINGS CUNNINGHAM.
SAYING NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
CLERK LOGAN THE ROLE. DESERVE
IT ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF
THE- ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE
TO VOTE. CLICK WELL. CLOSE THE
ROLL TIDE BUT I FIFTY NINE NO
ZERO. THAT MEASURE PASSES FILE
ITEMS TO A FIVE THREE TWO OH
SEVEN PASS RETAIN. FILE ITEM TO
AWAIT SB TWO SEVEN FOUR.
SEPARATE SENATE BILL TWO
SEVENTY FOUR BY SENATOR DODD
AND OTHERS AND ACTUALLY THE
MOBILE HOME RESIDENCY MISS THE
MARK THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
CALIFORNIA HAS A HOUSING CRISIS
AND MOBILE HOMES ARE ONE OF THE
FEW AFFORDABLE HOUSING OPTIONS
THIS BILL HELPS TO KEEP THIS
SOURCE OF HOUSING AFFORDABLE
AND HELPS TO KEEP SENIORS AND
DISABLED PEOPLE IN THEIR HOMES
THE BILL CLARIFIES COMPANION
LANGUAGE FROM TWENTY SEVENTEEN
SB ONE FORTY SEVEN. ALLOWING UP
TO THREE TOTAL COMPANIONS ARE
KEPT UNDER YEAR SECOND IF THE
MOBILE HOME PARK IS DESTROYED
BY A WILDFIRE OTHER NATURAL
DISASTER THIS BILL WOULD OFFER
PREVIOUS HOMEOWNERS THE FIRST
OFFER TO LIVE IN THE PARK IF IT
IS REBUILT THIRD THIS BILL
PROVIDES A CLEAR FRAMEWORK FOR
WHAT PARK MANAGEMENT SHALL
CONSIDER WHEN APPROVING OR
DENYING A PROSPECTIVE PURCHASER
AND WHAT PERSPECTIVE PURCHASERS
CAN PROVIDE TO PARK MANAGEMENT.
THE GOAL OF ALL THESE CHANGES
ARE TO HELP VULNERABLE
CALIFORNIANS BECAUSE OF AGE
DISABILITY INCOME OR SOME
COMBINATION THERE OF MOBILE
HOMES ARE ONE OF THE LAST
VESTIGES OF AFFORDABLE HOUSING
THIS BILL HAS NO OPPOSITION AT
RISK. I VOTE. THANK YOU MISS
EMMA. SAYING NO DISCUSSION ON
THE ITEM. CLARK LIBERAL
MEMBERS. ARE TO VOTE ALL
MEMBERS OF THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OF THE DESIRE TO
VOTE. WELL. THE CLOTHES ARE ALL
TIED UP I FIFTY SEVEN KNOWS
ZERO. THAT MEASURE PASSES WERE
TO PASS TEMPORARILY I'M FILING
TO TWELVE WE'RE ALSO PASSING
AND RETAINING ON FILE ITEMS TWO
OR NINE THREE TO ELEVEN WE'RE
GOING TO PASS RETAIN ON FILE
ITEMS TO THIRTEEN. THREE TO
FIFTEEN. WE WILL TAKE UP. WHILE
I'M TO SIXTEEN SB FOUR THIRTY
EIGHT CORPORATION SAMPLE FOR
THIRTY EIGHT BY SENATOR
HERTZBERG AND OTHERS AND
ACTUALLY TO EMERGENCY SERVICES.
DOCTOR EGGMAN. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR SPEAKER MEMBERS
MEMBERS I HOPE YOU HAVE NEVER
HAD TO WORRY WHEN YOU'VE EVER
HAD TO CALL NINE ONE AND I HOPE
YOU HAVEN'T HAD TO CALL NINE
ONE ONE TOO MANY TIMES IN YOUR
LIFE UNFORTUNATELY I HAVE. AND
WHEN YOU CALL NINE ONE ONE THE
LAST THING YOU WANT TO THINK
ABOUT IS THAT THE PERSON WHO IS
DISPATCHING AND COMING TO YOUR
HOME IS WORRIED ABOUT THEIR
BOTTOM LINE. BECAUSE THE BOTTOM
LINE SHOULD BE ABOUT THE SAFETY
AND THE CARE OF OUR
CONSTITUENTS. SB FOUR THIRTY
EIGHT PROHIBITS A PUBLIC AGENCY
FROM DELEGATING ASSIGNING OR
CONTRACTING ITS LOCAL EMERGENCY
DISPATCH SERVICES TO A PRIVATE
FOR PROFIT ENTITY EXCEPT OF ITS
UNDER PURSUANT TO A JPA WITH
OTHER LOCAL NON PROFITS.
MEMBERS AGAIN THIS HELPS KEEP
OUR PUBLIC SERVICES ARE PUBLIC
EMERGENCY SERVICE PUBLIC IT
SHOULDN'T BE CONCERNED ABOUT
THE BOTTOM LINE WHEN YOU CALL
NINE ONE ONE. FOR ALL OF.
MEMBERS I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE
SB FOUR THIRTY EIGHT. EIGHT OCT
REGNANT SAYING NO DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THE ITEM CORP LOCAL
ROLE. MODELS ARE VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE THIS ADDED VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
VOTE. CLERK WILL. CLOSER ALL
TALLIED ABOUT EYES FIFTY FOUR
KNOWS FOR. THAT MEASURE PASSES
PASS RETAIN OF VIOLENCE TO
SEVENTEEN TO EIGHTEEN. FILE
ITEM TO NINETEEN SB SIX EIGHTY
ONE QUIRK REYES SENATE BILL SIX
EIGHTY ONE BY SENATOR STERN AND
I PLAN TO ELECTIONS OCCURRING
THERE AND SEE THEIR UP TO TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY. MISTER
CALDERON. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS LAST YEAR THE
LEGISLATURE APPROVED SB ELEVEN
FIFTY THREE STERN TO PERMIT
PROPONENTS OF COUNTY MUNICIPAL
OR SPECIAL DISTRICT INITIATIVE
TO WITHDRAW THEIR MEASURES AT
ANY TIME BEFORE THE EIGHTY
EIGHT THE DAY. BEFORE THE
ELECTION WHETHER OR NOT THE
PETITION HAS ALREADY BEEN FOUND
SUFFICIENT BY ELECTION
OFFICIALS SB SIX EIGHTY ONE
SIMPLY EXTENDS THIS IS THIS
AUTHORITY TO A LOCAL REFERENDUM
OR CHARTER AMENDMENT. THIS BILL
IS SUPPORTED BY US YEAH YOU IN
THE CITY OF SACRAMENTO AND IS
SUPPORTED BY THE LEAGUE OF
CALIFORNIA CITIES AS WELL AS
THE LEAGUE OF WOMEN VOTERS SB
SIX ANYONE HAS NO OPPOSITION
HASN'T RECEIVED ANY NO VOTES
ARE RESPECTFULLY ASK. FOR AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MATT BROWN
SEE NO DISCUSSION DEBATE CLUB
CLUB IN THE WRONG ALL MEMBERS
OF. THE DESIRE TO VOTE ON
MEMBERS OF THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
VOTE. CLARK WELL CLOSER ALL
TIED UP I SIXTY FOUR NO ZERO ON
THE URGENCY I SIXTY FOUR NO
ZERO ON THE MEASURE. THAT BILL
PASSES MEMBERS WERE WERE TO
MOVE BACK IN THE FILE TO TAKE A
FILE I'M TO TWELVE. SB TWO TWO
SEVEN BY. PRESENTED BY MISS
BETH CORKERY SAMPLE TO TWENTY
SEVEN BY SENATOR LEYVA AND
ACTUALLY TO HEALTHCARE
FACILITIES MISS SMITH. THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER GOOD
AFTERNOON MEMBERS AS YOU MAY
REMEMBER SEVERAL OF YOU SAW
SIMILAR VERSION OF THIS BILL
LAST YEAR SB TWELVE EIGHTY
EIGHT WHICH WAS UNFORTUNATELY
VETOED BY THE FORMER GOVERNOR.
NURSE TO PATIENT RATIOS ARE
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT FOR BOTH
THE COUNTLESS PATIENTS TO SEE
KAREN HOSPITALS AS WELL AS THE
NURSES WHO WORK HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. AS THE DAUGHTER OF
A LIFELONG CAREER NURSE WHO
WORKED IN ABOUT EVERY
DEPARTMENT THAT ONE CAN IMAGINE
IN A HOSPITAL THERE IS NO MORE
VEXING AND PERSISTENT AN ISSUE
THAT MY MOM WOULD MENTION THEN
THE RATIOS SHE FACED WHETHER AS
A FLOOR NURSE OR A CHARGE NURSE
IN THE HOSPITAL SHE WORKED IN
AND FOR THE PATIENT SHE TOOK
CARE OF. SB TWO TWO SEVEN
EMPOWERS THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH TO
ENSURE PATIENT SAFETY BY
ENFORCING MANDATED LONGSTANDING
NURSED RATIOS. FINING HOSPITALS
THAT REPEATEDLY BREAK THE
STANDARD. FROM TO THAT AND
EIGHT TO TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN
THERE WERE A TOTAL OF SIX
HUNDRED THIRTY FOUR OUT OF
RATIO DEFICIENCY ALLEGATION
REPORTED. EIGHTY P. H. THE
DEPARTMENT'S PRESENT
ENFORCEMENT MEASURES ARE SIMPLY
NOT ENOUGH AS IT CONDUCTS
INSPECTIONS EVERY THREE YEARS
TO ENSURE THAT HOSPITALS ARE
COMPLYING WITH THE LAW. THIS
PERIODIC CHECK IS FAR TOO
INFREQUENT AND ALLOWS HOSPITALS
TO PREPARE BEFORE CD PH
OFFICIALS CONDUCT THEIR
INSPECTIONS. SB TWO TWO SEVEN
WOULD ADDRESS THIS PROBLEM BY
REQUIRING THAT THE DEPARTMENT
CONDUCT UNANNOUNCED VISITS TO
INSPECT FOR COMPLIANCE WITH
NURSING STAFF REQUIREMENTS.
THIS MEASURE WOULD ALSO EMPOWER
THE DEPARTMENT TO ENFORCE THE
STAFFING REQUIREMENTS WITH
FINES IN CASES WHERE THOSE
RATIOS HAVE BEEN VIOLATED. SB
TWO TWO SEVEN IS VITALLY
IMPORTANT SO WE CAN PROTECT
PATIENT HEALTH AND SAFETY HERE
IN CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU MISTER
MISS KOREA. YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I'M PROUD TO STAND IN
SUPPORT OF SB TWO TWO SEVEN
ALSO A BILL THAT I AM PROUD TO
CO AUTHOR. SB TWO TWO SEVEN
WILL PROTECT PATIENTS AND
ENSURE SAFER CONDITIONS FOR
PATIENT CARE BY ENFORCING.
CURRENT NURSES STAFFING RATIOS
ACTUALLY BE IMPLEMENTED NURSES
ARE INSTRUMENTAL IN PROVIDING
NECESSARY AND OFTEN TIMES
LIFESAVING CARE IN OUR
CALIFORNIA HEALTH FACILITIES MY
GRANDMOTHER WAS A NURSE AND SHE
WOULD OFTEN TELL ME. OF ALL
STORIES THAT SHE FACE WHILE
WORKING IN THE HOSPITAL OFTEN
BEING UNDERSTAFFED THIS BILL
ENSURES NURSES ARE PERFORMING
THEIR JOBS WITH ADEQUATE
ASSISTANCE AND HOSPITALS ARE.
ARE PROPERLY STAFF TO PROVIDE
THE HIGHEST QUALITY OF PATIENT
CARE I HOPE THAT YOU ALL STAND
IN SUPPORT OF SB. TWO SEVEN
THANK YOU. A RISK HERE MISTER
BONTA. YOUR LAST THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES I
RISE IN SUPPORT OF SB TWO
TWENTY SEVEN IS A PRIVATE CO
AUTHOR IT'S BEEN TWENTY YEARS.
SINCE GOVERNOR DAVIS SIGNED A.
B. THREE NINETY FOUR AND FIRST
ENACTED NURSE TO PATIENT RATIOS
IN CALIFORNIA AND OVER. THE TWO
DECADES SINCE. ACROSS THE STATE
WE FOUND TWO THINGS FIRST
STAFFING RATIOS IMPROVE
WORKPLACE SAFETY AND THE
QUALITY OF PATIENT CARE. AND
TOO MANY HEALTH CARE FACILITIES
AND HOSPITALS ARE NOT
CONSISTENTLY FOLLOWING. THOSE
200-082-2017 THERE WERE SIX
HUNDRED AND THIRTY FOUR OUT OF
RATIO VIOLATIONS REPORTED TO
THE DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH. AND LET US REMEMBER
THAT THE STAFFING RATIOS ARE
THE ABSOLUTE MINIMUM. THAT A
FACILITY SHOULD BE OPERATING
UNDER NOT THE IDEAL. OR THE
TYPICAL STAFFING SO WE MUST ACT
NOW TO PROTECT OUR PATIENTS WHO
ARE AT RISK EVERY DAY DUE TO
THESE VIOLATIONS WE ARE
COMMITTING A DISSERVICE TO
PATIENTS. AND HEALTH CARE
PROFESSIONALS ALIKE BY. AND FOR
BEING PROVEN LOPS ESPECIALLY
WHEN PEOPLE'S LIVES ARE AT
STAKE SB TWO TWENTY SEVEN WILL
ENSURE THAT PATIENTS ARE ONLY
ASSISTED AND- THAT NURSES ARE
BEST SITUATED TO PROVIDE
EXCELLENT CAN CARE. BY NOT
WORKING BE ON THERE THE
PASSAGE. BACKLIT FREE AYE VOTE
ALEX. THANK YOU WHICH BONTA.
THANK YOU MEMBERS MISTER
SPEAKER. YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS MEMBERS I RISE TODAY IN
SUPPORT OF SB TWO TWO SEVEN
JUST AS I ROSE LAST YEAR TO
SUPPORT A SIMILAR BILL WE WORK
HARD TO THE EXPAND ACCESS TO
HEALTH CARE AND WE ARE STILL
WORKING TO MAKE SURE THAT
EVERYONE IS COVERED. FOR EVERY
CAL POIGNANT PATIENT HEALTH AND
SAFETY SHOULD BE A GIVEN TO DO
THAT WE NEED TO PROTECT THE
HUMAN RELATIONSHIP WE NEED TO
MAKE SURE THAT CARE GIVER THERE
THIS BILL HELPS TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE CURRENT LAW A NURSE TO
PATIENT RATIO WAS FOLLOWED I
HOPE YOU DO AS THIS HOUSE DID
LAST YEAR AND APPROVE THIS BILL
WE NEED TO SEND IT TO THE
GOVERNOR. FOR HIS SIGNATURE I
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE SB TWO
TWO. THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
AND THANK YOU MEMBERS FOR THE
DEBATE. MISS SMITH YOU MAY
CLOSE. LIKE TO THANK MISTER
SPEAKER MY COLLEAGUES FOR THEIR
SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE I
STRONGLY URGE AN AYE VOTE LET'S
LET NURSES BE GREAT NURSES
THANKS. WITHOUT CLERK LIBERAL
MEMBERS OF DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS HAVE THE DESIRE TO
VOTE
. CLARK WELL. CLOSE YOUR
ROLL TIDE OF A AYE AYES FORTY
FOUR KNOWS FIFTEEN. THAT
MEASURE PASSES. BACK IN FILE
ORDER FILE ITEM TO TWENTY PASS
RETAIN. FILE ITEM TO TWENTY ONE
IS SB TWENTY ONE. CORPORATION
SENATE BILL TWENTY ONE BY
SENATOR DODD AND ACTUALLY THE
ALCOHOLIC BEVERAGES DECLARING
THE URGENCY THERE UP TO TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY MR GRAY
DAVIS BIGGER MEMBERS SB TWENTY
ONE IS THE FOLLOW UP BILL TO
LEGISLATION LAST YEAR IT
RELATES TO THE MINIMUM BREWING
REQUIREMENTS FOR SMALL BREWERS
THIS TAKES ABOUT TWO HUNDRED
BARRELS PER YEAR TO ONE HUNDRED
BARRELS PER YEAR FOR TYPE
SEVENTY FIVE LICENSE. THIS IS
AN EXCELLENT BILL YOU'RE NOT
GOING TO MISS THE OPPORTUNITY
VOTE FOR THIS PAST YEAR I ABOUT.
THANK YOU MISS GRAY. A SINGLE
DISCUSSION DEBATE CARPAL OF THE
ROLE REVERSAL. THE VOTE ON
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
THIS TAKES FIFTY FOUR. ALL
MEMBERS VOTED TO SARAJEVO
.
CLARK WELL. CLOSER ROLE TALLY
THE VOTE I FIFTY SEVEN NO ZERO
ON THE URGENCY I FIFTY SEVEN NO
ZERO ON THE MEASURE. THAT BILL
PASSES. FILE ITEM TO TWENTY TWO.
SB THIRTY NINE CORPORATE SENATE
BILL THIRTY NINE BY SENATOR
HILL AND OTHERS AND ACTUALLY
TOBACCO PRODUCTS MR MCCARTY.
YOUR MAIL. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I'M HERE TODAY TO
PRESENT SB THIRTY NINE PART OF
OUR EFFORTS TO ADDRESS THE
YOUTH E. CIGARETTE EPIDEMIC
WERE FACING OUR NATION AND OUR
STATE THIS WILL IMPOSE STRICTER
AGE VERIFICATION REQUIREMENTS
FOR TOBACCO PRODUCTS SOLD
ONLINE LIKE WE SEE WITH ALCOHOL
WE'VE HAD A SUCCESS IN MAKING
SURE THAT ALCOHOL SALES WHEN
PURCHASED ONLINE HI PROPER
VERIFICATION RESEARCH SHOWS IS
ONE OF THE EASIEST WAY FOR
YOUNG PEOPLE TO BUY E.
CIGARETTES BORROW A FAMILY
MEMBERS A CREDIT CARD. MAKE AN
ONLINE ORDER AND MAKE SURE YOU
PICK IT UP WITH NO ADULTS ARE
ROUNDS AGAIN THIS IS MODELED
AFTER A SUCCESSFUL SYSTEM WE
HAVE HERE IN CALIFORNIA WITH
ALCOHOL MAKE SURE THAT
CONTAINERS OF OUT OF TOBACCO
PRODUCTS HAVE A CERTAIN LABEL
THAT SAYS CONTAINS TOBACCO%
PRODUCTS SIGNATURE OF PERSON
TWENTY ONE YEARS OF AGE OR
OLDER REQUIRED FOR DELIVERY IN%
ALL CAPS LETTERS THIS ROSS
REQUIRE THE VENDORS TO OBTAIN A
SIGNATURE OF ALL PERSONS TWENTY
WENT OVER BEFORE DELIVERING A
TOBACCO PRODUCT. THIS IS A
SMART MEASURE BUILDS UPON OUR
SUCCESS WE ALREADY HAVE FOR THE
ALCOHOL INDUSTRY AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR EMAIL
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISS
MCCARTY MISTER GRAY YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS I RISE ALSO IN
SUPPORT OF SB THIRTY NINE THIS
IS AN IMPORTANT COMPONENT OF A
PACKAGE OF BILLS THAT WE'VE
WORKED ON ALL YOUR WITH BOTH
MEMBERS IN OUR HOUSE AS WELL AS
THE SENATE TO ADDRESS THE
FRANKLY EPIDEMIC THAT WE'RE
SEEING WITH TEAM PEIPING AGE
VERIFICATION IMPORT CAR. THAT I
RESPECTFULLY DR VOTE. ON BOARD.
THANK WAS GREAT. SEEING NO
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION. ON THE
ITEM QUIRK LIBERAL. DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS OF THE DESIRE
TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT
OF. CLARK WELL. CLOSER ALL TIED
UP BUT I SIXTY SEVEN NO ZERO
THAT MEASURE PASSES. PAST
RETAIN A FILING TO TWENTY THREE
PASS TEMPORARILY ON FILE AND
TWO TWENTY FOUR. PASS AND
RETAIN ON TWO TWENTY FIVE. THAT
BRINGS US TO FILE ITEM TO
TWENTY SIX SP ONE SIXTY FIVE
FOR THE PURPOSE OF AMENDMENT.
CARPOOL READ WITH AMENDMENTS
SENATE BILL ONE SIXTY FIVE WITH
THE MOMENTS BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BONTA. SURE BONTA ON THE
AMENDMENTS. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES I RISE
TO PRESENT AMENDMENTS TO SB ONE
SIXTY FIVE BY SENATE PRESIDENT
PRO TEM ATKINS. THE AMENDMENTS
ARE CLEAR FINING TECHNICAL IN
NATURE. THE BILL HAS RECEIVED
NO NO VOTES AND HAS NO
OPPOSITION I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE ON THESE
MOMENTS. THANK YOU MISS BONTA.
SEE NO DISCUSSION DEBATE AND
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A
VOICE VOTE ON THESE AMENDMENTS
ALL THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE. AYE
OPPOSED SAY NAY. THE AYES HAVE
IT THE AMENDMENTS ARE ADOPTED
THE BILLS OUT TO PRINT AND BACK.
ON FILE FILE ITEMS TO TWENTY
SEVEN. THREE TO THIRTY. PASS
RETAIN. FILE ITEM TO THIRTY ONE
IS SB TWO THIRTY FIVE FOR THE
PURPOSE OF AMENDMENT CLERK WILL
READ WITH AMENDMENTS SENATE
BILL TWO THIRTY FIVE WITH THE
MINUTES BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
AGUIAR-CURRY. MS AGUIAR-CURRY
ON THE MENACE. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I RISE TO PRESENT
AMENDMENTS TO SB TWO THIRTY
FIVE FOR SENATOR DODD. THESE
ARE TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS TO
CONFORM THE BILL TO THIS YEAR'S
BUDGET ACT I ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. HE WAS AGUIAR-CURRY
SENIOR DISCUSSION ON THE
AMENDMENTS AND WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A VOICE
VOTE ALL THOSE IN FAVOR SAY
AYE. AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY. THE
AYES HAVE IT. THE AMENDMENTS
ARE ADOPTED BILLS OUT OF PRINT
AND BACK ON FILE. FILE ITEM TO
THIRTY TO PASS AND RETAIN. FILE
I'M TWO THIRTY THREE SB TWO
SIXTY SEVEN. CORPORATION SENATE
BILL TWO SIXTY SEVEN BY SENATOR
WHITE HOUSE SKI AND ACTUALLY TO
DRIVER'S LICENSES MR FALL. I
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS IS MY PLEASURE TO
PRESENT SB TWO SIXTY SEVEN AND
WE HAVE A CENTER Y. CASKEY AS
WE TO SIXTY SEVEN WOULD PROVIDE
FOREIGN SERVICE OFFICERS AND
THEIR SPOUSES AN EXTENSION ON
THEIR DRIVER'S LICENSES WHILE
THEY'RE SERVING ABROAD SO THAT
REMAINS VALID UNTIL THEY ARE
ABLE TO RETURN HOME. CALIFORNIA
ALREADY PROVIDES THE EXTENSION
FOR THOSE IN THE ARMS FORCES
AND THEIR SPOUSES WHY THEY ARE
ALSO SERVING OUT OF STATE THIS
BILL HAS PASSED WITH UNANIMOUS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND HAS NO
OPPOSITION. I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST DRIVE OUT. THANK YOU
MISS FONG SI NO DISCUSSION
DEBATE. OR PULL UP TO THE ROLE
OF. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO
VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE
TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE
THOSE. QUIRK WELL. CLOSER ROLE
TELL A VOTE I SIXTY ONE KNOWS
ZERO. THAT MEASURE PASSES FILE
ITEM TO THIRTY FOUR SB THREE OH
SIX CARPOOL READ SENATE BILL
THREE OH SIX BY SENATOR MORALE
AND ACTUALLY MORTGAGE MORTGAGES
MR OBERNOLTE THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER RISE ON BEHALF OF
SENATOR REAL TO PRESENT SB
THREE OH SIX REAL PROPERTY
TRUSTEES HAVE A VERY IMPORTANT
ROLE IN PROPERTY TRANSACTIONS
IN CALIFORNIA THIS IS A
RELATIONSHIP OF TRUST THAT CAN
LAST FOR DECADES. HOWEVER
CALIFORNIA STATE LAW CURRENTLY
HAS NO PATH FOR TRUSTEES TO
RESIGN IF THEY SO WISH THIS
BILL SB THREE OH SIX CREATES
SUCH A PATH THIS BILL HAS PER
ENJOYED BROAD BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT AND I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST DROP. NAME IS ROBIN ALL
THE SAME NOTE STRUCTURE BATES
CLARK LOCAL ROLE. NUMBERS PHONE.
THESE ARE NOT ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBER
SERVICE ARE TO VOTE. CLARK WELL
CLOSE THE ROLL TIDE ABOUT AYE
SIXTY TWO KNOWS ZERO. THAT
MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEMS TO
THIRTY FIVE. THREE TO THIRTY
SEVEN PASS RETAIN THIS IS FILE
ITEM TWO THIRTY EIGHT SB THREE
EIGHTY FIVE CORPORATION SENATE
BILL THREE EIGHTY FIVE BY
SENATOR JONES ACTUALLY
PROFESSIONS AND VOCATIONS MR OF
ARNOLDI THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER RISE ABOUT HALF OF
SENATOR JONES TO PRESENT SB
THREE EIGHTY FIVE THIS BILL
AMENDS THE PRIVATE INVESTIGATOR
ACT WITH A NUMBER OF CLEAN UP
PROVISIONS IT ALSO CREATES. A
PORTABLE LICENSE FOR PRIVATE
INVESTIGATORS TO CARRY THIS
WOULD ENHANCE CONSUMER
PROTECTION BY ALLOWING
CONSUMERS TO IDENTIFY WHICH
INVESTIGATORS ARE PROPERLY
LICENSED THIS BILL IS ENJOYED
BROAD BIPARTISAN SUPPORT I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE. THEY MISTER OVER NINETY
EIGHTEEN NO DISCUSSION OF A
LOCAL OF THE ROLE. SORRY ABOUT
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLARK WELL. CLOSER ROLL TIDE
ABOUT AYE SIXTY TWO KNOWS ZERO
THAT MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEM
TO THIRTY NINE IS SB THREE
EIGHTY SEVEN CORPORATION SENATE
BILL THREE EIGHTY SEVEN BY
SENATOR WILK AND OTHERS AND
ACTUALLY THE SANTA CLARITA
VALLEY WATER AGENCIES. MR
LACKEY. WELL GOOD MORNING
SPEAKER MEMBERS I RISE TO
PRESENT SENATE BILL THREE
EIGHTY SEVEN ON BEHALF CENTER
WELL. THIS BILL IS A CLEAN UP
OF THE SENATORS SB SIX THIRTY
FOUR FROM TWENTY SIXTEEN WHICH
CREATED THE SANTA CLARITA
VALLEY WATER AGENCY AS A
CONSOLIDATION OF TWO PREVIOUS
AGENCIES. ONE OF THE PROVISIONS
IN THE SENATE BILL REQUIRES THE
AGENCY'S BOARD OF DIRECTORS TO
REDUCE ITS MEMBERSHIP TOTAL
FROM FIFTEEN TO NINE. BY
CONSOLIDATING SEATS SENATE BILL
THREE EIGHTY SEVEN AUTHORIZES
THE AGENCY'S BOARD OF DIRECTORS
TO ELIMINATE A BOARD POSITION
UP THERE IS A VACANCY PRIOR TO
THE NEXT ELECTION. THIS IS
NEEDED TO AVOID EITHER ELECTION
OR APPOINTMENT PROCESS FOR SEAT
THAT IS REQUIRED TO BE
ELIMINATED ONE OF THE NEXT TO
ELECTIONS. THIS BILL
ESTABLISHES A METHODOLOGY TO
FAIRLY ESTABLISH WHICH SPEECH
GET TWO AND FOUR YEAR TERMS OF
THIS AUTHORITY IS EXERCISED.
IT'S SURPRISE OF SEATS ARE
CONSULTED OR ARE TO AN ELECTION.
A LOT TO DETERMINE WHICH SEATS
TO RECEIVE TWO AND FOUR YEAR
TERMS WILL OCCUR. THIS BILL IS
SPONSORED BY THE AGENCY AND HAS
RECEIVED UNANIMOUS SUPPORT THUS
FAR I ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT VOTE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MITCHELL
IKEY MISS SMITH YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER COLLEAGUES I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE I THINK
ARE SENATOR WHO OVERLAPS IN MY
NEIGHBORING ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FROM THE ANTELOPE VALLEY FOR
THIS MEASURE I'M THIS IS A
RESULT OF A SERIES OF COMMUNITY
MEETINGS THAT HAVE HAPPENED ARE
COMMUNITIES THOSE BY THIS WATER
AGENCY ARE WELL AWARE OF WHAT
THIS PROCESS WILL LOOK LIKE BUT
THIS CLEAN UP BILL ALLOWS US TO
MOVE ON MUCH MORE
EXPEDITIOUSLY. INCITING ABOARD
AND SEATING ABOARD FOR THIS
WATER AGENCY THAT WILL SERVE
WHOLE COMMUNITIES HERE I VOTERS
APPRECIATED. NAME IS SPELLED C.
NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION.
CORPORATE FUNDS ARE VOTE ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A. ALL
MEMBERS OTHERS ARE ABOUT. WELL.
CLOSE ARE ALL TIED UP I SIXTY
FIVE NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES FILE ITEMS TO FORTY
THROUGH TWO FORTY THREE PASS
RETAIN. FILE ITEM TO FORTY FOUR
SB FIVE SIX NINE CLERK WILL
READ SENATE BILL FIVE SIXTY
NINE BY SENATOR STONE AND
ACTUALLY CONTROLLED SUBSTANCES.
MR GALLAGHER. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I'M HAPPY TO PRESENT SB
FIVE SIXTY NINE ON BEHALF OF
SENATORS STONE. THIS BILL
ADDRESSES IMPORTANT ISSUE THAT
WAS IDENTIFIED IN THE WAKE OF
THE CAMPFIRE AND WILL HELP
ENSURE THAT DISPLAYS
INDIVIDUALS HAVE ACCESS TO
THEIR MEDICATIONS DURING THE
RECENT FIRE SIGNIFICANT DAMAGE
OCCURRED TO EXISTING
INFRASTRUCTURE AND HEALTH CARE
FACILITIES. LEAVING THIS PLACE
PEOPLE WITH LIMITED ACCESS TO
PRESCRIPTION MEDICATIONS. WHILE
SOME EMERGENCY MEASURES ARE
AVAILABLE TO HELP PROVIDE
ACCESS DURING A DECLARED
DISASTER MANY PATIENT CARE
AREAS ARE ESTABLISH AN
EMERGENCY SHELTERS PUBLIC
SCHOOLS AND CHURCHES THESE
NONTRADITIONAL MEDICAL PATIENT
CARE SETTINGS MAY NOT HAVE
ACCESS TO STATE MANDATED
CONTROLLED SUBSTANCES. SECURITY
FORMS LIMITING THE PATIENTS
ACCESS TO THEIR MEDICAL CARE SB
FIVE SIXTY NINE WILL FIX THIS
BY CREATING A LIMITED EXEMPTION
TO THE CONTROLLED SUBSTANCES
FORMS REQUIREMENT DURING THE
INITIAL PHASE OF A LOCAL STATE
OR FEDERALLY DECLARED DISASTER.
SB FIVE SIXTY NINE HAS NO
OPPOSITION IS PERHAPS THE
SENATE AND ASSEMBLY COMMITTEES
UNANIMOUSLY WITHOUT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR RIVAL.
THANK YOU MISTER GALLAGHER. SEE
IF SHOWN DISCUSSION ON THE ITEM
CARPOOL OVER THE ROLE ALL
MEMBERS OF. THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE. DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE
TO VOTE. CLICK WELL CLOSER ALL
TIED ABOUT AYE AYES SIXTY FIVE
NO ZERO. THAT MEASURE PASSES. I
WISH WE ARE GOING TO PASS AND
RETAIN. ON FILE ITEMS TO FORTY
FIVE TO FORTY SIX. IN TWO FORTY
SEVEN. FILE ITEM TO FORTY EIGHT.
IS SB SIX TWENTY THREE. SENATE
BILL SIX TWENTY THREE BY
SENATOR JACKSON AND ACTUALLY TO
HOUSING. MISTER NAZARIAN EMAIL
BUT- THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
SB SIX TWENTY THREE DIRECT THE
DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT TO USE
THE MOST CURRENT CENSUS DATA.
AVAILABLE TO DETERMINE THE
AMOUNT OF ASSISTANCE THE
DEPARTMENT PROVIDES FOR THE
BUILDING OF HOUSING FOR SENIOR
CITIZENS THROUGH ITS MULTI
FAMILY HOUSING PROGRAM IT ALSO
MAKES TECHNICAL CORRECTIONS TO
CORRECT REFERENCES TO DELETED
STATUTES. OVER THE NEXT TWO
DECADES CALIFORNIA SENIOR
POPULATION IS EXPECTED TO
NEARLY DOUBLE IT WILL BE 87%
HIGHER IN TWENTY THIRTY THAN IT
WAS IN TôI TWENTY TWELVE. MORE
THE SENIORS ARE PROJECTED TO BE
LIVING ALONE THAN PREVIOUSLY IT
IS CRITICAL THAT WE CONSIDER
WHAT ADDITIONAL HOUSING
RESOURCES THE SENIORS WILL NEED
AND THE TYPES OF HOUSING
PROVIDED FOR SENIORS WILL BE
CRUCIAL IN MEETING THIS NEED.
THE DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT IS
PRESENTLY USING THE AMERICAN
COMMUNITY SURVEY THIS BILLCODIFIES AN EXISTING PRACTICE
BY USING THE MOST ACCURATE DATA
TO ASSESS THE NUMBER OF SENIOR
CALIFORNIANS WE WILL USE OUR
HOUSING RESOURCES MORE WISELY
TO MEET THE NEEDS OF THE
STATE'S SENIOR RESIDENTS. WITH
THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK WHERE I
VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER NAZARIAN.
SAY NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THE ADAM CLERK LIBERAL. ALL
MEMBERS OF. DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS OF THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSER ALL TIED
UP I SIXTY FIVE KNOWS ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSES. FILE ITEM TO
FORTY NINE IS SB SIX THIRTY TO
THE CORPORATION SENATE BILL SIX
THIRTY TWO BY CENTER GALGIANI
AND OTHERS AND ACTUALLY TO
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY. MR
GALLAGHER. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I AM PROUD
TO PRESENT ANOTHER MEASURE THAT
IS EQUALLY IMPORTANT IN THE
AFTERMATH OF. THE WILD FIRES
THAT WE'VE SEEN WE KNOW THAT
THE NUMBER ONE THING WE CAN DO.
TO PREVENT THESE CATASTROPHIC
WILDFIRES LIKE WE SAW ON THE
TUBS FIRE IN THE CAR FIRE THEY
CAN'T FIRE IS TO ENSURE
VEGETATION IN FORESTRY
MANAGEMENT IN THIS STATE THAT
HAS BEEN SORELY LACKING. TWELVE
YEARS AGO THE BOARD OF FORESTRY
AND FIRE PROTECTION PROPOSED A
PROGRAMMATIC E. I. R. FOR OF
VEGETATION TREATMENT PROGRAM IS
PART OF A COMPREHENSIVE FIRE
PREVENTION STRATEGY. THAT STILL
HAS NOT BEEN COMPLETE THIS BILL
SB SIX THIRTY TWO DIRECTS THE
STATE BOARD OF FORESTRY AND
FIRE PROTECTION TO COMPLETE AND
CERTIFY THE I. R. FOR
VEGETATION TREATMENT PROGRAM NO
LATER THAN FEBRUARY FIRST.
TWENTY TWENTY THE GOVERNOR HAS
ALSO CALLED ON THE BOARD OF
FORESTRY TO DO THE SAME. THE
KEY JACKET OF THE PROGRAM ARE
TO PREVENT LOSS OF LIVES AND
PROPERTY REDUCE FIRE
SUPPRESSION COSTS AND PROTECT
NATURAL RESOURCES FROM DAMAGING
WILDFIRE THROUGH THE USE OF
APPROPRIATE VEGETATION
TREATMENTS. I ARE WILL SPEED UP
THE PROCESS FOR MANY MUCH
NEEDED VEGETATION FORESEE
MANAGEMENT PROJECTS THROUGHOUT
THE STATE. IN FACT THIRTY EIGHT
HAVE BEEN IDENTIFIED ALREADY
AND ARE IN THE WORKS. AND SO I
WOULD I WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
IT HAS NO OPPOSITION. AND I
WOULD ASK YOUR AYE VOTE MEMBERS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISTER
GALLAGHER. SEE NO DISCUSSION
DEBATE ON THE ITEM. CAR CLUB
THE ROLE ALL MEMBERS. DESIRE TO
VOTE ON MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS OTHERS ARE TO
VOTE. CLICK WELL. CLOSE ROLL
TIDE ABOUT I SIXTY SIX NO ZERO
THAT MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEMS
TWO FIFTY AND TWO FIFTY ONE
PASS AND RETAIN. THIS IS FILE
ITEM TWO FIVE TWO. SB SIX SEVEN
NINE THE CORPORATION SENATE
BILL SIX SEVENTY NINE BY
SENATOR BATES AND OTHERS AND
ACTUALLY THE HEALING ARTS
MISTER PATTERSON. BUT MISS
SPEAKER UP MEMBERS I RISE TO
PRESENT THE SB SIX SEVEN NINE
ON BEHALF OF SENATOR BATES I'M
ALSO A CO AUTHOR OF THE BILL
THIS BILL STREAMLINED THE
PROCESS FOR INDIVIDUALS WHO
HELD A LICENSE FOR AT LEAST TWO
YEARS IN ANOTHER STATE. FOR
THREE SPECIFIC PROFESSIONS
MARRIAGE AND FAMILY THERAPIST
CLINICAL SOCIAL WORKERS AND
PROFESSIONAL CLINICAL
COUNSELORS UNDER CURRENT LAW
THESE OUT OF STATE LICENSEES
BUT MUST MEET ALL EDUCATION AND
EXPERIENCE REQUIREMENTS THAT A
BRAND NEW APPLICANT MUST MEET
EVEN IF THEY HAVE BEEN LICENSE
FOR MANY YEARS OR EVEN DECADES
IN THEIR OWN HOME STATE. SB SIX
NINE SEVEN HONORS THE
EXPERIENCE THAT LICENSEES HAVE
ACCUMULATED IN THEIR HOME
STATES WHILE STILL MAKING SURE
THEY OBTAIN THE NECESSARY
COURSE WORK TO UNDERSTAND
CALIFORNIA SPECIFIC LAWS AND
HELP THEM PRACTICE EFFECTIVELY
IN CALIFORNIA'S ENVIRONMENT.
THIS PROPOSAL IS CONSISTENT
WITH EFFORTS AT THE NATIONAL
LEVEL AND ALSO IT COMES UP FROM
A RECOMMENDATION OF
CALIFORNIA'S LITTLE HOOVER
COMMISSION THIS BILL ALSO HELPS
ADDRESS THE CRITICAL SHORTAGE
OF MENTAL HEALTH PROFESSIONALS
THE CALIFORNIA CURRENTLY FACES.
SB SIX NINE SEVEN IS SPONSORED
BY THE BOARD OF BEHAVIORAL
SCIENCES AND HAS RECEIVED
UNANIMOUS SUPPORT THUS FAR IN
BOTH HOUSES AT RISK. FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU IS PATTERSON
SEEING. YEAH SURE DEBATE ON THE
ITEM. CAR CLUB IN THE ROLE ALL
MEMBERS. THESE ARE VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS OTHERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE. DESIRE TO VOTE.
WELL CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT I
SIXTY SIX NO ZERO. THAT MEASURE
PASSES
. A RUSSIAN FILE ORDER
FILE I'M TO FIFTY THREE. SB SIX
EIGHT EIGHT CORPORATE SENATE
BILL SIX EIGHTY EIGHT BY CENTER
MINING AND ACTUALLY TO
EMPLOYMENT. YOUR KALRA HE MAY
OPEN THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS SB SIX EIGHT GIVES THE
LABOR COMMISSIONER THE
AUTHORITY TO COMBAT WAGE THAT
FOR UNPAID CONTRACTUAL WAGES
WITH CITATION PROCEDURE
DIRECTLY WITH THE EMPLOYER.
THIS BILL WILL ENSURE WORKERS
ARE PAID THEIR PROPERTY
CONTRACTUAL WAGES IN A TIMELY
MANNER BY PERMITTING UNPAID
CONTRACT WAY JUST BE COLLECTED
IN LIEU OF A LONGER COURT
PROCESS CURRENTLY THE LABOR
COMMISSION HAS THE AUTHORITY TO
ASSESS UNPAID MINIMUM AND
OVERTIME WAGES WHISTLER
CITATION PROCEDURE AGAINST A
PLAYER. THE OTHER TO
COMMITMENTS REMOVE ALL
OPPOSITION RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE. THERE WAS KALRA.
SAYING NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THE ITEM. CLARK LOCAL
MEMBERS OF THE CEREMONY ALL
MEMBERS OTHERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF. CLARK
WELL. CLOSER ALL TELL A VOTE I
FIFTY THREE KNOWS TWELVE THAT
MEASURE PASSES. FILE ITEM TWO
FIFTY FOUR IS SB SEVEN
SEVENTEEN. CORPORATION SENATE
BILL SEVEN SEVENTEEN BY SENATOR
JONES AT NECKLINE ALCOHOLIC
BEVERAGES THIS BOERNER HORVATH
FEMALE BUT THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER CURRENT LAW A LAW
OFFERS TIED HOUSE EXEMPTION TO
ALCOHOL MANUFACTURERS THAT
ALLOWS THEM TO BUY ADVERTISING
SPACE THE STADIUMS AND SPORTS
ARENAS WELL IT'S EXISTING
PRACTICE TO INCLUDE CRAFT
DISTILLERS IN THIS EXEMPTION
CURRENT LAW DOES NOT
SPECIFICALLY NAME THEM. SB
SEVEN SEVENTEEN SIMPLY ADDS
CRAFTED STORAGE THE EXEMPTION
IN ORDER TO MAINTAIN CONSISTENT
INTERPRETATION OF THE LAW THIS
MEASURES PASSED UNANIMOUSLY I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THINGS BOERNER HORVATH
SEEN NO DISCUSSION DEBATE
CARPOOL OF THEY'RE ALL. ALL
MEMBERS RUN TO SARAH VOTE ALL
MEMBERS VOTE. WE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OF OUR DESIRE TO
VOTE. WELL CLOSER ALL TELEVOTE
EYES SIXTY FOUR NO ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSES. FILE ITEM TO
FIFTY FIVE PASSED RETAIN. FILE
IN TWO FIFTY SIX IS SB SEVEN
EIGHTY TWO. CORPORATION SENATE
BILL SEVEN EIGHTY TWO BY THE
COMMITTEE ON LABOR PUBLIC
EMPLOYMENT AND RETIREMENT AND
ACTUALLY THE PUBLIC RETIREMENT
SYSTEMS MAKING A PREPARATION
THEREFORE. MISS RODRIGUEZ YOU
MAY OPEN. MISS SPEAKING MEMBERS
I RISE TO PRESENT. SB SEVENTY
TWO BY THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON
LABOR PUBLIC EMPLOYEES
RETIREMENT THIS BILL IS THE
ANNUAL CALPERS TECHNICAL CLEAN
A BILL THAT SIMPLY MAKES NON
CONTROVERSIAL. TECHNICAL
CHANGES TO MAINTAIN ENSURE
EFFECTIVE ADMINISTRATION OF THE
SYSTEM ARE STRICTLY OUT FOR I
WILL. THANK YOU MISS RODRIGUEZ
SEEING NO DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CLARK WILL OPEN THE ROLE. THE
DESIRE TO VOTE ON MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF A- ALL MEMBERS OF.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE. CLICK WELL
CLOSER ALL. HOWEVER I SIXTY
FIVE KNOWS ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES FOR ONE PASS RETAIN ON
FILE TWO FIFTY SEVEN. WHERE
FILE ITEM EIGHT. SB SEVEN
EIGHTY SEVEN CLERK WILL READ
SENATE BILL SEVEN EIGHTY SEVEN
BY THE COMMITTEE ON AGRICULTURE
AND ACTUALLY THE ANIMAL
WELFARE. DOCTOR EGGMAN. THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS FILE
ITEM TO THE. THISSB SEVEN
EIGHTY SEVEN AGRICULTURE BILL
BACK FOR CHATTERING OUT
AMENDMENTS VERY SIMPLE UNLIKE
THE PRESENTATION I ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE. A DOCTOR EGGMAN.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THE ITEM CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE MEMBERS. IT IS OUR VOTE
ALL MEMBERS MEMBERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE CLERK WILL. CLOSER ROLL
TIDE ABOUT I SIXTY SIX NO ZERO
THAT MEASURE PASSES. BALLOT IN
TWO FIFTY NINE IS SB TWO THIRTY
TWO. CORPORATION SENATE BILL
TWO THIRTY TWO BY SENATOR DODD
AND OTHERS AND ACTUALLY TO
HAZARDOUS SUBSTANCES. MS GARCIA
YOU MAY OPEN THANK YOU SB TWO
THIRTY TWO CONFORMS CALIFORNIA
A LOT TO THE TOXICS AND
PACKAGING FEARING HEALTH MODEL
LAW. WHICH SETS TO ENTER PARTS
PER MILLION AT THE MAXIMUM
ALLOWABLE AMOUNT A HEAVY METALS
IN ADDITION TO STANDARD HELP
THE GLASS INDUSTRY MADE SEVERAL
OTHER IMPORTANT ENVIRONMENTAL
GOALS AND **** AND SET A
JANUARY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY
FOUR I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. NAME IS GARCIA SAY NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
ITEM. CAR CLUB MEMBERS OF. IS
THAT ABOUT ALL MEMBERS ABOUT
THE START OF THE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE WHO IS OUR TO VOTE. CLICK
WELL CLOSER ALL TIED UP. I SIX
SIXTY SIX KNOWS ZERO. THAT
MEASURE PASSES PASS RETAIN A
FILE ITEM TO SIXTY. THIS IS
FILE ITEM TO SIXTY ONE. SB SIX
SEVENTY FOUR CLERK WILL READ
SENATE BILL SIX SEVENTY FOUR BY
SENATOR MCGUIRE AND OTHERS AND
ACTUALLY TRIBAL GAMING
DECLARING THEIR AND SEE THEIR
UP TO TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY.
DOCTOR WOULD YOU MAIL. THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS
SB SIX SEVENTY FOUR RATIFIES
THE TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
TRAVEL COMPACT RECOUP OF VALLEY
TRIED IN HUMBLE COUNTY WITH THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. COOPER
VALLEY TRIBE IS ONE OF THE
LARGEST TRIBES IN THE STATE IN
TERMS OF TRUST LAND IN
POPULATION IN HUMBLE COUNTY THE
TRIBE IS THE SECOND LARGEST
EMPLOYER IN THE COUNTY. COMPAQ
WILL ALLOW THEM TO FURTHER GROW
THE LOCAL ECONOMY AND SUPPORT
THEIR COMMUNITY. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
DOCTOR WOULDN'T. SEEN NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
ITEM. FOR CLUB HOWEVER SERVICE
OUT OF A. ALL MEMBERS OTHERS AT
ABOUT. ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE
TO VOTE. CLARK WELL CLOSER ROLE
SALLY VOTE I SIXTY SEVEN NO
ZERO ON THE URGENCY I SIXTY
SEVEN NO ZERO ON THE MEASURE.
THAT BILL PASSES. FILE ITEM TO
SIXTY TWO IS SB SIXTY FOUR
CONCRETE SENATE BILL SIXTY FOUR
BY SENATOR CHIANG AND OTHERS
AND EXPLAIN TO ANIMALS. MISTER
KALRA. THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS SB SIXTY FOUR REQUIRES
ANIMAL SHELTERS TO MICROCHIP
ANY DOG OR CAT WITH CURRENT
INFORMATION THAT IS EITHER
ADOPTED OR CLAIMED BY A PET
OWNER IN CALIFORNIA HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF SHELTERS DOT
SHELTER DOGS AND CATS ARE
EUTHANIZED EVERY YEAR. A
SIGNIFICANT SOURCE OF THE
PROBLEM IS ANIMAL
IDENTIFICATION AND THE ABILITY
TO UNITE THESE ANIMALS WITH
THEIR FAMILIES. ONLY 15% OF
DOGS AND 2% OF CATS AND
SHELTERS WITHOUT IDENTIFICATION
I REUNITED WITH THEIR OWNERS BY
CONTRAST ACCORDING TO THE
JOURNAL OF THE AMERICAN
VETERINARIAN MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION ALMOST THREE FORCE
OF LOST MICROCHIP CATS AND DOGS
LOCATED DUE TO THE PRESENCE OF
THE MICROCHIP. SB SIXTY FOUR
WILL ULTIMATELY HELP PREVENT
DOGS AND CATS FROM BEING
NEEDLESSLY SHELTERED OR
EUTHANIZE BY PROMOTING PET
OWNERSHIP REUNIFICATION I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
ON SB SIXTY FOUR. FAMOUS KALRA.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION DEBATE OUR
GLOBAL ROLE. THE DESIRE TO VOTE
ON MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OTHERS OUT OF A.
CLARK WELL CLOSER ALL. TIE THE
VOTE I SIXTY SIX NO ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSES. FILE ITEM TO
SIXTY THREE IS SB TWO TWO NINE.
SENATE BILL 229% HERTZBERG
ACTUALLY TO IMPLEMENT. MISS
KOREA YOU MAY OPEN. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I AM
PROUD TO PRESENT SB TWO TWENTY
TWO ON BEHALF OF OUR COLLEAGUE
IN THE SENATE WHICH BUILDS ON
PREVIOUS LEGISLATION THAT
PROVIDED TIMELY RELIEF TO
WORKERS WHO FACE RETALIATION
FROM THEIR EMPLOYERS IN TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN SB THREE OH
SIX GAVE NEW TOOLS TO THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER'S OFFICE AND TO
WHISTLE BLOWERS TO GUARANTEE
THEIR RIGHTS AND SAFETY
FOLLOWING SB THREE OH SIX WE
FOUND THAT CERTAIN TECHNICAL
FIXES WERE NECESSARY TO FULLY
ACHIEVE THE GOAL OF THAT
LEGISLATION. SB TWO TWO NINE
SOLIDIFIES WHISTLE BLOWER
RIGHTS BY STRAIGHTENING THE
LABOR COMMISSIONER'S ABILITY TO
CARRY OUT JUST A JUST
LITIGATION PROCESS THIS BILL
FILLED IN DETAILS ON THAT FINAL
STATE OF THAT OF THE CITATION
AN APPEAL PROCESS AND CLARIFY
THE COMMISSIONERS OF THE
ALREADY TO ENFORCE A CITATION
TO WORK QUICKLY TO PROVIDE
WORKERS THERE AND RELIEF IT
ALSO SPECIFY THAT EMPLOYEES I'M
SORRY EMPLOYERS. WHO RECEIVED
CITATIONS ARE ENTITLED TO AN
INFORMAL HEARING AS OPPOSED TO
A FORMAL ONE WHICH ALIGNS WITH
THE PROCESS ISSUED BY THE
DIVISION OF LABOR STANDARDS
ENFORCEMENT ON SIMILAR
INVESTIGATION SB TWO TWO NINE
CEMENTS THE LEGISLATURE'S
PREVIOUS COMMITMENTS TO PROVIDE
TRANSPARENT AND TIMELY
RESOLUTIONS AND IT IS A STRONG
STEP FORWARD IN PROVIDING
WHISTLEBLOWER PROTECTION. I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MS CREEL.
SAYING NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON
THE ITEM CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE. ALL MEMBER SERVICE ARE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE. THE
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. CLARK WELL.
CLOSE YOUR ROLL TIDE ABOUT EYES
FORTY EIGHT KNOWS TWELVE. THAT
MEASURE PASSES
. EVER IS BACK ON
THE FILE FILE ITEMS TO SIXTY
FOUR. THROUGH. TWO SEVENTY FIVE
PASS RETAIN. THIS IS FILE ITEM
TO SEVENTY SIX SB SIX FIFTY SIX
FOR THE PURPOSE OF AMENDMENTS
HER CAREER WITH AMENDMENTS
SENATE BILL SIX FIFTY SIX WITH
THE MEMONS BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GLORIA. MR GLORIA ON THE
MINUTES THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I RISE RESENT TECHNICAL
AMENDMENTS TO SB SIX FIFTY SIX
THESE MINUTES COME AT THE
REQUEST OF CALTRANS **** THE
MINUTES BE ADOPTED. AND THIS
BILL BE PLACED OUT TO PRINT AND
PUT BACK ON FILE. THANK YOU
MISS GLORIA SEE NO DISCUSSION
ON THE AMENDMENT SO WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A VOICE
VOTE ALL THOSE IN FAVOR SAY
AYE. AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY. YES
HAVE AT THE MEMBERS ARE ADOPTED
THE BILL'S OUGHT TO PRINT. AND
BACK ON FILE. FILE ITEM TWO
SEVENTY SEVEN IS SB ONE FIFTY
FIVE CORPORATE. SENATE BILL ONE
FIFTY FIVE BY SENATOR BRADFORD
AND ACTUALLY TO ENERGY. DOCTOR
QUIRK THANK YOU SPEAKER IN
MEMBERS SB ONE FIFTY FIVE
IMPROVES COMPLIANCE INCREASES
INCREASES ACCOUNTABILITY FOR
THE RENEWABLE PORTFOLIO
STANDARD AND INTEGRATED
RESOURCE PLAN. THIS MEASURE
WILL ALLOW CALIFORNIA IN THE
PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION TO
PROACTIVELY MANAGE CONCERNS IN
SHORT FALLS THE BILL IS
SUPPORTED BY Q. THE COALITION
OF UTILITY EMPLOYEES TURN THE-
UTILITY REFORM NETWORK. AND
RECENT AMENDMENTS OF BECAUSE
THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY CHOICE
ASSOCIATION AND MOST CCA'S TO
GO NEUTRAL I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
DATA QUIRK SEEN NO DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THE ADAM. LOCAL OF
THE ROLE. DESIRE TO VOTE ALL
MEMBERS VOTE DESIRED ABOUT. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLARK WELL. CLOSER ALL TELL THE
VOTE. I SIXTY THREE NO ZERO
THAT MEASURE PASSES WERE GONNA
PASS TEMPORARILY ON FILE ITEM
TWO SEVENTY EIGHT. ASCERTAIN ON
FILE ITEMS TO SEVENTY NINE
THROUGH TWO. EIGHTY TWO. AND
MISTER CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR PROCEDURAL
MOTION THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
I REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND THE RULES TO ALLOW
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GRAY TO TAKE UP
HIS A. B. SIXTEEN THIRTY NINE
WITHOUT REFERENCE THE FILE FOR
THE PURPOSE OF THIRD READING.
THAT OBJECTION A MEMBERS THIS
IS. FILE ITEM NUMBER ONE IN
TODAY'S DAILY FILE WITHOUT
REFERENCE TO FILE. WITHOUT
REFERENCE TO FILE THIS IS AB.
SIXTEEN THIRTY NINE.
CORPORATION ASSEMBLY BILL
SIXTEEN THIRTY NINE BY
SOMETHING MEMBER GRAY AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY TOBACCO
PRODUCTS KIND THERE IS EITHER
UPS TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY. MR
GRAY MAY OPEN. THANK YOU FOR
SPEAKER MEMBERS AB SIXTEEN
THIRTY NINE IS THE PRODUCT OF
MONTHS OF CONVERSATION
COMPROMISE MOST COLLEAGUES IN
THIS HOUSE. THE BILL BEFORE US
PROHIBITS VAPING COMPANIES FOR
ADVERTISING USING PACKAGING HAS
ATTRACTED TO CHILDREN INCLUDING
BANNING THE USE OF CARTOON
MASCOTS IN PACKAGING RESEMBLING
CANDY. THE BILL RAMPS UP
PENALTIES ON RETAILERS AND
STRAW PURCHASERS TO PROVIDE
THESE PRODUCTS TO KIDS AND
REQUIRES THE DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH CONDUCT ONGOING
STING OPERATIONS OF NO LESS
THAN 20% OF THE TOTAL NUMBER OF
LICENSED RETAILERS. THE BILL
ALSO IMPOSES MORE STRINGENT AGE
VERIFICATION REQUIREMENTS ON
THE TOBACCO SALES AND PROHIBITS
ANYONE UNDER THE AGE OF TWENTY
ONE FOR ENTERING A TOBACCO SHOP.
AMENDMENTS TAKEN COMMITTEE OF
BROUGHT GROUPS LIKE THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
AMERICAN HEART AND LUNG
ASSOCIATION THE TOBACCO FREE
KIDS ACTION FIND IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL. AB SIXTEEN THIRTY
NINE REPRESENTS A MULTI PRONGED
APPROACH TO CLOSE YOUTH ACCESS
POINTS INCREASING
ACCOUNTABILITY FOR THOSE THAT
VIOLATE THE LAW. RESTRICTING
EXPOSURE TO THESE PRODUCTS AND
PROVIDING OPPORTUNITIES FOR
CONTINUED OVERSIGHT AND
EDUCATION ON THIS ISSUE. WITH
MORE THAN THREE AND A HALF
MILLION SCHOOL. MIDDLE SCHOOL
AND HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS
REPORTING E. CIGARETTE USE.
LAST YEAR TEEN VAPING HIS TRULY
REACHED EPIDEMIC PROPORTIONS.
THERE WAS A 78% INCREASE IN THE
USE AMONG HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS
BETWEEN TWENTY SEVENTEEN AND
TWENTY EIGHTEEN. THE RISE OF
THE CIGARETTES USE AMONG
STUDENTS IS ERODING DECADES OF
PROGRESS TOWARD GAME TOBACCO
OUT OF THE HANDS OF KIDS. THE
FDA AND CDC ARE BEGINNING TO
TAKE ACTION AT THE FEDERAL
LEVEL BUT IN THE MEANTIME
CALIFORNIA'S FILL THAT VOID
THAT IS LOUD TEENS ACCESS TO
CIGARETTES AT RATES NOT SEEN IN
TRADITIONAL CIGARETTES FOR
DECADES. THIS IS A BIPARTISAN
ISSUE MEMBER IT'S A BIPARTISAN
BILL. AB SIXTEEN THIRTY NINE IS
AUTHORED BY BOTH DEMOCRATS AND
REPUBLICANS IS RECEIVE
UNANIMOUS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT IN
BOTH HEALTH COMMITTEE AND
APPROPRIATIONS AND I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR RIVAL
HERE TODAY. THANK YOU MISS GRAY.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THE ITEM. CLICK CLUB IN THE
ROLE OF ALL MEMBERS VOTE. IT IS
OUT OF IT ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
ARE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS OF THE
DESIRE TO VOTE
. THE CLERK WILL.
CLOSER ROLE TALENT BUT I SIXTY
SEVEN NO ZERO ON THE URGENCY I
SIXTY SEVEN NO ZERO ON THE
MEASURE. THAT BILL PASSES.
MEMBER CHAU RECALL THAT WE PASS
TEMPORARILY ON FILE ITEM TO
TWENTY FOUR. SB ONE FIFTY ONE
SURE BERMAN NOW RATE TAKE THAT
MEASURE UP. CARPOOL BRIEF
SENATE BILL ONE FIFTY ONE BY
SENATOR UMBERG AND ACTUALLY TO
ELECTIONS MR BERMAN. YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES SB ONE
FIFTY ONE ALLOWS AN ELECTED
STATE OFFICIAL WHO SUBJECT TO A
RECALL ELECTION TO HAVE THEIR
PARTY PREFERENCE IDENTIFIED ON
THE RECALL BALLOT. UNLIKE THE
ELECTED OFFICIAL BEING RECALLED
CANDIDATES SEEKING TO SUCCEED
THE ELECTED OFFICIAL ARE
CURRENTLY ABLE TO HAVE A PARTY
PREFERENCE IDENTIFIED IN
ADDITION THERE BEEN RECENT
INSTANCES WHERE VOTERS RECEIVE
THEIR VOTE BY MAIL BALLOTS
BEFORE THEIR COUNTY VOTER
INFORMATION GOT ARRIVED. IN
RESPONSE THIS BILL REPEALS
PROHIBITION ON COUNTY VOTER
INFORMATION GUIDES BEING SENT
TO VOTERS MORE THAN FORTY DAYS
BEFORE AN ELECTION. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANKS BERMAN. SAYING NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
ITEM CLERK WILL OPEN ROLL. ALL
MEMBERS OF. DESIRE TO VOTE ON
MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS HAVE THE DESIRE TO
VOTE. CLARK WELL CLOSER ROLE
TODD ABOUT I SIXTY NINE NO ZERO
THAT MEASURE PASSES
. MISTER
CALDERON YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR PROCEDURAL MOTION. THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO SUSPEND%
SUSPEND JOINT WILL SIXTY TWO A
THE FILE NOTICE REQUIREMENT TO
ALLOW THE HEALTH COMMITTEE TO
HEAR A. B. FIFTEEN TWENTY NINE
LOW ON THURSDAY SEPTEMBER FIFTH
AT NINE. THIRTY AM IN ROOM
FORTY TWO OH TWO. WITHOUT
OBJECTION THE REQUEST IS
GRANTED
. MEMBERS WE ARE GOING
TO MOVE THE CONSENT CALENDAR
BUT WE ARE NOT GOING TO LIVE TO
QUORUM CALL THERE MAY BE
ADDITIONAL BUSINESS BEFORE. THE
HOUSE. WARM CALL STAYS IN PLACE
WE ARE MOVING TO A VOTE ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. WE'RE GOING
TO PASS RETAIN ON FILE ITEM.
TWO EIGHTY EIGHT. SB SEVENTY
ONE
. IS A MEMBER WHICH REMOVE
AN ITEM FROM THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. SEEING AND HEARING
NONE. THE CLERK READ THE SECOND
EXACT COUNT OR- HOUSE
RESOLUTION FIFTY FOUR BY
SOMETHING MEMBER KAMLAGER-DOVE
AND OTHERS A RELATIVE TO
VETERANS IN THE ARTS AND
HUMANITIES DAY. LOCAL OVER THE
WRONG. REPRESENTATIVE OF ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS OF THE DESIRED ABOUT.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE ABOUT
THIS IS THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
CLARK WELL. CLOSER ALL EYES TO
SEVENTY. NO ZERO THE CONSENT
CALENDAR IS ADOPTED
. MEMBERS A
QUORUM CALL REMAINS IN PLACE
MOVING TO ANNOUNCEMENTS
SECESSION SCHEDULE IS AS
FOLLOWS WEDNESDAY SEPTEMBER
FOURTH CHECK IN SESSION.
THURSDAY SEPTEMBER FIFTH FLOOR
SESSION IS AT TEN AM AND FRIDAY.
SEPTEMBER SIXTH FLOOR SESSION
STARTS AT NINE AM PROMPTLY.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO MOVE AT
THIS TIME TO ADJOURNMENTS IN
MEMORY AND MEMBERS I WOULD ASK
THAT YOU GIVE YOUR RESPECTFUL
ATTENTION TO YOUR COLLEAGUES.
THE QUORUM CALLS IN PLACE
PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS SO WE
MAY GIVE OUR RESPECTFUL
ATTENTION TO OUR COLLEAGUES WHO
ARE CHURNING IN THE MEMORY.
PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS AT THIS
TIME MEMBERS. THE FOLLOWING
MEMBERS. WE'RE GRANTED PRIOR
PERMISSION TO SPEAK ON A GERMAN
IN MEMORY. MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE
YOUR SEATS. SO WE MAY PROCEED
WITH THE GERMANS AND MEMORY. MR
BLOOM YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
GERMANY MEMORY THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS I RISE TO
ADJOURN IN THE MEMORY OF
LEGENDARY ACTOR AND DIRECTOR
PETER FONDA WHO DIED ON AUGUST
SIXTEENTH A COUPLE WEEKS AGO AT
THE AGE OF SEVENTY NINE AND IT
WAS A LONG TIME RESIDENT OF
ASSEMBLY DISTRICT FIFTY. HE WAS
BROTHER OF ACTRESS JANE FONDA
AND THE SON OF ACTOR PETER
FONDA SO ONE OF THOSE TRULY
LEGENDARY SHOWBIZ FAMILIES. HE
WAS BORN IN NEW YORK ON
FEBRUARY TWENTY THIRD THE
TWENTY THIRD NINETEEN FORTY AND
STARTED HIS CAREER ON BROADWAY
IN NINETEEN SIXTY ONE AND
DIRECTED HIS FIRST FILM. IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY ONE IN
NINETEEN NINETY EIGHT AT THE
AGE OF FIFTY SEVEN HE WAS
NOMINATED FOR A BEST ACTOR
ACADEMY AWARD FOR HIS ROLE AS A
BEE KEEPER TRYING TO HOLD THIS
FAMILY TOGETHER. IN THE
INDEPENDENT FILM YOU LEASE
GOLD. THE NEW YORK TIMES SAID
OF HIS PERFORMANCE IT WOULD BE
ACCURATE BUT BARELY ADEQUATE TO
CALL THIS THE FINEST WORK OF
FUND IS CAREER. HE WENT ON TO
STAR IN A NUMBER OF FILMS AND
TELEVISION SHOWS BUT FUND IS
CAREER WOULD BE FOR EVER
DEFINED BY HIS NINETEEN SIXTY
NINE. BREAKOUT ROLE AS WHY IT
WITH THE STARS AND STRIPES
HELMET ASTRIDE HIS MOTORCYCLE.
WHICH WAS NAMED CAPTAIN AMERICA
IN THE FILM THAT I'LL BET. JUST
ABOUT EVERYONE IN THIS ROOM IS
SEEKING. EASY RIGHT. HE WAS A
ROUGH HEWN CHARACTER IN THAT
FILM THAT WAS OFTEN REFLECTED
IN HIS TUMULTUOUS PERSONAL LIFE.
PETER FONDA PRODUCED AND CO
SCRIPTED EASY RIDER FOR HIS
WORK AND FOR HIS WORK ON THAT
PROJECT. HE EARNED AN ACADEMY
AWARD NOMINATION FOR BEST
ORIGINAL SCREENPLAY. TURNER
CLASSICS CLASSIC MOVIES CALLED
EASY RIDER ON ONE LEVEL THE
STORY OF TWO DRUG DEALERS WHO
BECAME RICH FROM A COCAINE DEAL
BUT THEY WENT ON TO SAY THAT
THE FILM IS MUCH MORE THAN THAT
AND SHOWS A DIVERSE CROSS
SECTION OF AMERICAN CULTURE
THAT ENCOMPASSES LIFESTYLE
EXPERIMENTATION INTOLERANCE.
AND WONDER LAST. THE BIKER
IMAGE IN THAT FILM IS ONE THAT
FUND A CULTIVATED FROM AN EARLY
AGE PARTLY BECAUSE HIS FAMOUS
FATHER OF HIS FAMOUS FATHER.
FONDA TOLD THE LOS ANGELES
TIMES THAT IT WAS HIS ROCKY
RELATIONSHIP WITH HIS FATHER
THAT LED HIM TO FIRST RIDE A
MOTORCYCLE MY DAD DIDN'T WANT
ME TO HE SAID I WAS LIKE IN
YOUR FACE FUND TO SAID. AS SOON
AS I COULD I BOUGHT A HARLEY.
HE PASSED AWAY. PEACEFULLY ON
THE MORNING OF AUGUST SIXTEENTH
WITH HIS FAMILY AT HIS SIDE. HE
IS SURVIVED BY HIS SISTER JANE
FONDA DAUGHTER BRIDGET FONDA
SON IN LAW DANNY ELFMAN SON
JUSTIN FONDA AND MANY
GRANDCHILDREN AND THEY ASKED
THAT WE RESPECTFULLY ADJOURNING
HAS MEMORY. THANK YOU MISTER
BLOOM. MISTER JONES SAWYER YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR GERMAN
MEMORY. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I RISE TO A GERMAN IN
THE MEMORY OF THE L. BROWN VIDA
SERVED AS A VISUAL ARTS CURATOR
AT THE CALIFORNIA AFTER
AMERICAN MUSEUM WHERE SHE
FOCUSES ON EXHIBITING THE WORK
OF CONTEMPORARY APPAN AMERICAN
ARTISTS. THE GRADUATED FROM
PEPPERDINE UNIVERSITY SHE ALSO
HELD A MASTERS IN PUBLIC ART
STUDIES FROM THE UNIVERSITY OF
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA SHE SERVED
AS THE PROJECT MANAGER FOR OUR
DISPLAYS IN DOWNTOWN LONG BEACH
CULVER CITY EL LOS ANGELES
BEFORE JOINING THE CALIFORNIA
AFRICAN AMERICAN ART MUSEUM.
WAS QUITE AN ARTIST HERSELF BUT
KNEW SHE HAD A TALENT HUNGER
AND DRIVE TO PROMOTE OUR
COMMUNITY THAT WAS BETTER
SUITED FOR TRADING EXHIBITS AND
DISCOVERING ARTISTS RATHER THAN
BEATING IN THIS BEING IN THE
SPOTLIGHT HERSELF. SHE ALSO
GAVE BACK TO OUR COMMUNITY BY
WORKING WITH THE LOCAL FIRE
DEPARTMENTS MENTORING PROGRAM
TO HELP AT RISK I MEAN AT
PROMISE TEEN BOYS LEARN ME.
MEDITATION TECHNIQUES SHE DID
THIS ALL WHILE BEING A SINGLE
MOTHER TO EVAN HER SON WHO WILL
BE TWENTY ONE IN SEPTEMBER. IN
TWENTY SIXTEEN SHE REUNITED
WITH A BOYFRIEND WILLIAM PEDIS
AND THEY WERE TO BE ENGAGE.
THEY WERE ENGAGED TO BE MARRIED
NEXT YEAR IN A Y. VIDA WAS THAT
SPARKLING PERSONALITY AND LOVED
LIFE TO HER EVERY DAY WAS A
WOK OF ART. AS SHE BATTLE WITH
CANCER THAT ADDED TO DID NOT
CHANGE SHE WAS STILL THE
SHINING STAR TO WALK THROUGH
THE DOOR WANTED TO KNOW HOW YOU
WERE DOING. AND GIVING
COMPLIMENTS SMILES AND HUGS.
ALWAYS I MEAN ALWAYS DRESSED TO
THE NINES AS SHE WOULD SAY SHE
DID HER VERY BEST TO BE AN
EXAMPLE OF PER FACTIONALISM.
SHE WENT HOME THE MORNING OF
AUGUST FOURTEENTH AND TRULY
LEFT A VOID FOR MANY. MEMBERS I
ASKED THAT WE DURING IN THE
MEMORY OF VITA L. BROWN. THANK
YOU MISTER JONES SAWYER. MR
GALLAGHER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
FOR GERMAN MEMORY. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS RISE
TODAY TO JOIN IN MEMORY OF TWO
LONG TIME YUBA COMMUNITY
COLLEGE. I EMPLOYEES AND
MEMBERS OF OUR COMMUNITY.
HATTIE DANE WALTON EIGHTY EIGHT
PASSED AWAY PEACEFULLY AT HER
HOME ON AUGUST FIFTH TWO
THOUSAND AND NINETEEN. SHE WAS
ONE OF THE MOST WARM LOVING
CHRISTIAN WOMEN I'VE EVER KNOWN.
IN FACT YOU COULD LEAVE A
MEETING WITH DAM WITHOUT JUST
FEELING GOOD BECAUSE SHE CARED
ABOUT YOU. SHE CARED ABOUT WHAT
HAPPENED TO YOU AND SHE WAS
ALWAYS THERE. TO GIVE GOOD
ADVICE SHE MOVED. TO THE YUBA
SUTTER AREA SIXTY FIVE YEARS
AGO. COMING FROM ARKANSAS HER
HUSBAND JOHN A LONG TIME
EMPLOYEE OF GALLAGHER RANCH
BILL TO LIVE HERE IN CALIFORNIA
RAISING FIVE CHILDREN. IN THOSE
FIVE CHILDREN WERE GENET J. D.
RANDY SUSAN AND GARY. THEY
CELEBRATED FIFTY YEARS OF
MARRIAGE BEFORE JOHN'S PASSING.
THEY WERE COMPASSIONATE PEOPLE
WHOSE CHRISTIAN FAITH
CONSISTENTLY LED THEM TO HELP
MANY IN THEIR COMMUNITY. THOSE
IN NEED AND OVER THE YEARS THEY
CONSISTENTLY SET ASIDE MONEY
EVERY MONTH TO HELP AN ORPHAN
IN AFRICA. THE FOOD AND
CLOTHING. THEY WERE EVENTUALLY
ABLE TO MEET HIM. AND IT WAS A
JOYOUS OCCASION FOR ALL. DAM
WAS A FOUNDING A LIFETIME
MEMBER OF THE LINDA CHURCH OF
CHRIST SHE LOVE QUILTING.
READING AND THE COMPANY OF HER
FAMILY AND CHURCH. SHE WAS A
LIGHT THAT TRULY SHINE BRIGHTLY
AND TOUCHED SO MANY. SHE IS
PRECEDED IN DEATH BY HER
HUSBAND AS I SAID A FIFTY YEARS
JOHN WALTON. HER CHILDREN.
EIGHT GRANDCHILDREN TWELVE
GREAT GRANDCHILDREN. AND HER
SISTER PAT. OF HEBREW SPRINGS
ARKANSAS. I ASK TODAY THAT WE
CLOSE IN THE LEVY MEMORY. OF
DANE WALTON. THANK YOU MISS
GALLAGHER AND YOUR AGAIN
RECOGNIZE FOR AN ADDITIONAL
GERMAN MEMORY. MEMBERS I ALSO
ASK THAT WE ADJOURN IN MEMORY
OF KAREN MORRISON KAREN WAS
BORN AND WENDELL IDAHO IN
NINETEEN FORTY FOUR AND MOVE
KIND OF ALL AROUND THE WEST
BEFORE SETTLING IN PLEASANT
GROVE CALIFORNIA IN THE
NINETEEN FIFTIES. SHE ATTENDED
AND GRADUATED GROVE ELEMENTARY.
AND BEGAN. HER FULL TIME
EMPLOYMENT AFTER GRADUATING
FROM IS NICOLAS HIGH SCHOOL AND
THEN YOU BECAUSE EACH. AT THE
YUBA COMMUNITY COLLEGE BEGIN IN
THE PRINT SHOP. AND EARNED HER
WAY INTO THE ADMINISTRATION
BUILDING. WITH THE COMBINATION
OF APTITUDE AN ATTITUDE. ALONG
WITH THE WILLINGNESS TO LEARN
ANY TASK. AND THEN OWN IT
FOREVER. KAREN ALSO WAS THE
FIRST IN HER COMMUNITY BEGIN AS
A FOUNDING MEMBER OF THE
PLEASANT GROVE FIRST AID SQUAD
IN NINETEEN SIXTY SEVEN A ONE
OF A KIND PUBLIC SAFETY TEAM.
AT THE VOLUNTEER FIRE
DEPARTMENT THAT WAS WOMEN ONLY.
DO THE DIFFICULTY OF GETTING
TRAINING AND SELL SUTTER COUNTY
KAREN BECAME CERTIFIED TO TEACH
CPR IN NINETEEN SEVENTY FOUR.
AND TAUGHT HUNDREDS OF
EDUCATORS FIRST RESPONDERS
PROFESSIONALS AND STUDENTS THE.
THE CPR TECHNIQUES THAT SAVE
LIVES. AFTER RETIREMENT FROM
CALL FROM YOU THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE IN TWO THOUSAND AND
THREE AND RIGHT UP UNTIL HER
ILLNESS PREVENTED IT KAREN WORK
PART TIME AND VOLUNTEER BUT THE
MIDDLE MOUNTAIN INTERPRETIVE
HIKES. FOR WHICH SHE WORKED IN
THE CAPACITY OF AN OPEN HIKES
COORDINATOR SECRETARY AND
VOLUNTEERED AS A BACK OF GOD.
HER WORK WAS INSTRUMENTAL IN
THE GROWTH AND SUCCESS OF
INTERPRETIVE HIKES IN THE
SUTTER BUTTES KEEPING. KEEPING
UP TO SIX THOUSAND SUTTER
BUTTES PARTNERS AND FANATICS
INFORMED. WITH SEMI ANNUAL
NEWSLETTERS AND SHE HELPED
FOSTER COMMUNITY AROUND THIS
UNIQUE LANDSCAPE. KAREN IS
PRECEDED IN DEATH BY HER FATHER
AND MOTHER. STEP FATHER ON
DOCKET. HER CHILDREN. HER
CHILDREN MATTHEW SPENCER AND
GERRY SIX GRANDCHILDREN AN AUNT
NUMEROUS COUSINS AND LOVING
NIECES AND NEPHEWS SHE HAD A
LARGE FAMILY AND TO ALL OF US
HE WAS A IS A SPECIAL PERSON IN
THE COMMUNITY AND I ASK THAT
YOU AND YOUR AND HER MEMORY
TODAY. THANK YOU MISTER
. AMS
GONZALEZ YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR GERMAN IN MEMORY. THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS IT'S
WITH A HEAVY HEART THAT I RISE
TODAY AND ASKED THAT WE ADJOURN
IN THE MEMORY OF CINDY GREEN.
CINDY DESCRIBE YOURSELF AS AN
AN APOLOGY JETTED DEMOCRATS AN
ANIMAL LOVER IN AN OREGON DUCKS
FOOTBALL FAN SHOULD A BEAUTIFUL
SOUL INDEED DEDICATED HER LIFE
TO HELPING OTHERS AND LOVING
HER DOGS. BEFORE RETIRING IN
TWO THOUSAND NINE CINDY WORKED
AS A PEDIATRIC NURSE FOR KAISER
FOR THIRTY YEARS AND FOR A
DECADE BEFORE THAT AS A
PEDIATRIC NURSE FOR SCRIPTS
HEALTH. CHOOSE A FORMER
EXECUTIVE BOARD MEMBERS SAN
DIEGO DEMOCRATS FOR QUALITY AND
SHE GIVES SO MUCH TIME AND
ENERGY ENSURING THE SUCCESS OF
MANY EFFORTS LIKE WOMEN'S
RIGHTS UNIVERSAL HEALTHCARE IN
EQUALITY FOR THE LGBT Q.
COMMUNITY. CITY LET HER LIFE
WITH PASSION AND WALKED THIS
WORLD PURPOSE AND EXTREME
KINDNESS. IN HER PASSING SHE
TEACHES US TO MAKE A CONSCIOUS
EFFORT TO REACH OUT AND CHECK
IN ON ONE ANOTHER. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK THAT YOU JOIN
ME IN A JOURNEY IN IN THE
MEMORY OF MISS AND AGREEING.
THANK YOU MISTER THOMAS. AND
MISS RUBIO YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
FOR GERMAN MEMORY THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I
RISE TODAY TO A DURING THE
MEMORY OF A DEAR FRIEND. DAVID
CASPER OR AS I REFER TO HIM AS
CASPER. WHO LEFT US ON AUGUST
TWENTY EIGHTH SURROUNDED BY HIS
FAMILY AT THEIR HOME IN WEST
COVINA. CASPER WAS A TRACK
ATHLETE. I OWE MONEY HIGH
SCHOOL MOUNT SAN ANTONIO
COLLEGE AND FRESNO STATE. WHILE
AT MOUNT SAN ANTONIO COLLEGE HE
CAPTURED THE NINETEEN FIFTY
THREE STATE CHAMPIONSHIP IN THE
EIGHT HUNDRED METERS. BECOMING
THE FIRST MOUNT SAC ATHLETE TO
WIN STATE CHAMPIONSHIP. AND SET
THE NATIONAL JUNIOR COLLEGE
RECORD. AT FRESNO STATE HE
CONTINUED TO IMPROVE HIS TIME
AND SET NEW RECORDS IN THE
EIGHT HUNDRED METERS THAT WENT
ON BROKEN FOR TWENTY YEARS.
AFTER A BRIEF STINT IN THE US
ARMY CASPER BECAME A HIGH
SCHOOL TEACHER FIRST OF MODESTO
AND THEN AT BOTTOM PARK HIGH
SCHOOL FROM NINETEEN SIXTY TWO
TO NINETEEN NINETY FIVE. HE
TAUGHT MATH ELECTRONICS AND
DRIVERS ED INCLUDES TRACK AND
CROSS COUNTRY. CASPER HELPED
DESIGN THE MOUNT SAC CROSS
COUNTRY COURSE AND WAS AN
INTEGRAL PART OF THE MOUNT SAC
CROSS. COUNTRY INVITATIONAL AND
MOUNT SAC REALLY. COMMITTEE. HE
WAS DEAN OF CROSS COUNTRY IN
THE CENTRAL VALLEY AND A
RESPECTED MEMBER OF THE C. I.
F. S. AS AND STATE CIF
COMMITTEES CASPER WAS HONORED
BY BEING INDUCTED INTO THE
FRESNO STATE TRACK AND FIELD
HALL OF FAME MOUNT SAN ANTONIO
CROSS COUNTRY HALL OF FAME AND
THE MOUNT SAN ANTONIO ATHLETIC
HALL OF FAME UPON RETIREMENT HE
REMAINED AN ACTIVE SUPPORTER OF
BOTTOM PARK HIGH SCHOOL AND
MOUNT SAC BY MENTORING THE NEW
GENERATION OF CROSS COUNTRY AND
TRACK STARS. MOST IMPORTANTLY
HE ENJOYED CHEERING ON HIS
GREAT GRANDCHILDREN AT A YELLOW
HIGH SCHOOL AND SPENDING TIME
HONORING THE ART OF PHOTOGRAPHY
A HOBBY WHICH HE PICKED UP UPON.
RETIREMENT AND EVEN ONE
COMPETITIONS FOR. HE ENJOYED
CREATING MEMORIES WITH HIS
CAMERA LENS MEMORIES THAT HAVE
TOUCHED AND WILL REMAIN IN THE
HEARTS OF HIS STUDENTS ATHLETES
FRIENDS AND FAMILY. HE IS
SURVIVED BY HIS WIFE ANNE
CHILDREN BOB DONNAN GENE AND
JUDY AND HIS GRANDCHILDREN. AND
BY HUNDREDS AND HUNDREDS OF HIS
FORMER STUDENTS THAT HE TOUCHED
WITH HIS KINDNESS AND HIS
POSITIVE ATTITUDE. MEMBERS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK THE WE ARE
DURING THE MEMORY OF DAVID
CASPER THANK YOU. THANK YOU MS
RUBIO. MEMBERS PLEASE BRING THE
NAMES THE DESK TO BE PRINT IN
THE JOURNAL. OUR QUEST TO
ADJOURN IN MEMORY WILL BE
DEEMED READ AND PRINTED IN THE
JOURNAL
. MEMBERS WE CAN
ENTERTAIN VOTE CHANGES AT THIS
TIME. PLEASE RAISE YOUR
MICROPHONES MR MAYES. SENATE
BILL TWO EIGHTY FOUR I TO KNOW.
VOTE CHANGE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MAYES SENATE BILL TWO EIGHTY
FOUR I TO KNOW. WE'RE
ENTERTAINING VOTE CHANGES AT
THIS TIME
. MISTER GIBSON THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR SPEAKER FILE
ITEM ONE NINETY ONE. I TO NOT
VOTING. VOTE CHANGE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GIPSON ASSEMBLY JOINT
RESOLUTION SEVEN I TO NOT
VOTING
. MISTER CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR PROCEDURAL
MOTION THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
I REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND THE RULES TO ALLOW
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GONZALEZ TO TAKE
UP SB TWO SEVEN SIX PAM WITHOUT
REFERENCE THE FILE FOR THE
PURPOSE OF THIRD READING THE
BURKE BUT THE BILL IS CURRENTLY
ITEM NUMBER TWENTY FOUR ON
TODAY SECOND READING FILE. MR
FLOOR FOR PROFESSOR WE OBJECT
FOR THE ROOMS AS FOR ROLL CALL.
MISTER CALDERON MOVES. AND
MISTER GIBSON THE SECOND STEP
THE RULES BE SUSPENDED MEMBERS
THIS IS A PROCEDURAL VOTE. THE
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE
CALDERON IS ASKING FOR AN I.
THOUGH MR FLOORS ASKING FOR NO.
THIS CALL AROUND ASKING. FOR AN
AYE VOTE. MR FLORA IS ASKING
FOR NOVA MEMBERS AS A
PROCEDURAL VOTE. SAYS
PROCEDURAL. THIS CALL AROUND
ASKING FOR NINE AND MR FLOORS
ASKING FOR NOW THE CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ALL ASSN FORTY SIX NOS
THIRTEEN THE RULES ARE
SUSPENDED WITHOUT REFERENCE TO
FILE. THIS IS SB TWO SEVEN SIX
CORPORATION SENATE BILL TWO
SEVENTY SIX BY SENATOR PAN AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY THE PUBLIC
HEALTH. MS GONZALEZ YOU MAY
OPEN. THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
I AM BEFORE YOU TODAY TO
PRESENT SB TWO SEVENTY SIX A
BILL NECESSARY TO PROTECT THE
SAFETY OF OUR CHILDREN AND
COMMUNITY AS OUR COUNTRY'S
EXPERIENCE LEADING THE LARGEST
NUMBER OF MEASLES INFECTIONS IN
OVER A QUARTER CENTURY. SB TWO
SEVENTY SIX MAINTAINS AND
RESTORES THE INTEGRITY OF
MEDICAL EXEMPTIONS TO LEGALLY
REQUIRED VACCINES FOR SCHOOL
ENROLLMENT. SB TWO SEVENTY SIX
ENSURES THAT STUDENTS WHO TRULY
NEED A MEDICAL EXEMPTION WILL
RECIEVE THE EXEMPTION WHILE
KEEPING THOSE SAME CHILDREN
SAFE AT SCHOOL BY ENSURING THAT
THERE IS COMMUNITY COMMUNITY.
THIS BILL PROTECTS THE RIGHTS
OF THESE CHILDREN TO ATTEND
SCHOOL IN INTEREST CALIFORNIANS
HAVE THE FREEDOM TO GO ABOUT
THEIR COMMUNITY WITHOUT IT
BEING AT RISK OF BEING INFECTED
WITH SIRIUS PREVENTABLE
DISEASES. ARI BEN ONE THOUSAND
TWO HUNDRED AND THIRTY FOUR
CASES OF MEASLES REPORTED THE
UNITED STATES THIS YEAR. THE
MOST CASES SINCE NINETEEN
NINETY TWO AND SINCE MEASLES
WAS DECLARED ELIMINATED IN TWO
THOUSAND. THEY'VE ALSO BEEN
FIFTY CASES OF MEASLES HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. INCLUDING MULTIPLE
CASES AT LA ACTS MANY OF WHICH
INVOLVED UNVACCINATED FOLKS
CATCHY MISSILES OVERSEAS AND
RETRAIN THE CALIFORNIA WITH THE
DISEASE AND THERE IS AN ONGOING
OUTBREAK IN BUTTE COUNTY. AS
REPORTED SAN FRANCISCO
CHRONICLE WHILE MEASLES HAS
BEEN BROUGHT TO CALIFORNIA ON
SEVERAL OCCASIONS THIS YEAR
UNLIKE OTHER STATES CALIFORNIA
HAS NOT SUFFERED A HUGE
OUTBREAK LIKE MUSES AFRICA
BEGAN IN DISNEYLAND IN TWENTY
FOURTEEN BECAUSE THE
LEGISLATURE TOOK ACTION BY
PASSING SB TWO SEVENTY SEVEN.
TO RESTORE COMMUNITY IMMUNITY
TO NEIGHBORHOODS IN CALIFORNIA.
SB TWO SEVENTY SEVEN PROVED
SUCCESSFUL IN RAISING THE STATE
VACCINATION RATES FOR EACH
ENTERING KINDERGARTEN CLASS TO
ABOUT NINETY FIVE PERCENT.
ENOUGH TO BEGIN RESTORING
COMMUNITY IMMUNITY. BUT THIS
PROTECTION IS BEING UNDERMINED
BY HANDFUL OF UNSCRUPULOUS
PHYSICIANS WERE PROFITING FROM
PUTTING CHILDREN AT RISK IN
MAKING OUR SCHOOLS LESS SAFE.
SB TWO SEVENTY SEVEN DID NOT
SUBSTANTIALLY CHANGE THE
GRANTING A MEDICAL EXEMPTIONS
BY PHYSICIANS. WHICH EXPECTED
EACH CHILD TO BE EVALUATED BY
THEIR ACTUAL PHYSICIAN WHO
REGULARLY CARED FOR THEM
RECEIVING THE EXEMPTION
APPLYING THE STANDARD OF CARE.
INSTEAD AFTER PET PASSAGE OF
TWO SEVENTY SEVEN WE WITNESS
PHYSICIANS TO ADVERTISE
EXEMPTIONS FOR CASH ON SOCIAL
MEDIA AND ON THE INTERNET. SOME
PARENTS WOULD POST THAT THEIR
CHILDREN'S PHYSICIAN REFUSED TO
GRANT A CHILD A MEDICAL
EXEMPTION SO THEY BOUGHT ONE
FROM A DISTANT POSITION. THE
RESULT OF THESE FAKE MEDICAL
EXEMPTIONS WITH A QUADRUPLING
OF THE PERCENTAGE OF MEDICAL
EXEMPTIONS IN THE STATE. IN A
DECLINE IN THE STATE
VACCINATION RATE BELOW 95% FOR
THE CURRENT SCHOOL YEAR. BUT
MORE CONCERNING OVER HUNDRED
SCHOOLS IN CALIFORNIA HAVE
MEDICAL EXEMPTION RATES AT OVER
10% WITH SOME AS HIGH AS FIFTY
PERCENT. MEANING STUDENTS AT
THE SCHOOLS ARE RISK FOR MAJOR
OUTBREAK AND ARE NO LONGER SAFE.
THESE SCHOOLS REPRESENT TENDER
FOR A DISEASE WILD FIRE THE CAN
FARM THE BROADER COMMUNITY.
CALIFORNIA CANNOT ALLOW A
HANDFUL ABOUT PHYSICIANS TO PUT
OUR CHILDREN IN DANGER
PARTICULARLY BABIES TOO YOUNG
TO BE VACCINATED AND CHILDREN
WHO GENUINELY NEED A MEDICAL
EXEMPTION. THAT'S WHY THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
AND THE CALIFORNIA AMERICAN
ACADEMY OF PEDIATRICS OR
SPONSORING SB TWO SEVENTY SIX
WITH THE PARENTS OF ACCIDENT
CALIFORNIA. PHYSICIANS ARE
HOLDING THEMSELVES IN THE
COLLEAGUES ACCOUNTABLE TO
PRACTICING QUALITY CARE BASED
ON SCIENCE AND TO KEEP THE
PUBLIC SAFE. WITH AMENDMENTS
TAKEN UP FOR THIS. BEGINNING A
TWENTY TWENTY ONE SB TWO
SEVENTY SIX WILL REQUIRE ALL
MEDICAL EXEMPTIONS BE FILED AT
THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH AND
PHYSICIANS WILL HENCEFORTH BE
REQUIRED TO SUBMIT REQUESTS FOR
MEDICAL EXEMPTIONS TO THE STATE
DEPARTMENT. OF HEALTH. THE
NUMBER OF THE- PEOPLE HAVE
WORKED ON THESE AMENDMENTS TO
ENSURE TWO THINGS. THOSE
EXEMPTIONS IT'LL BE IDENTIFIED
AND LOOKED AT OUR WHEN DOCTORS
PRESCRIBE OVER FIVE OF THEM A
YEAR MOST PEDIATRICIANS IF YOU
TALK TO THEM MIGHT HAVE DONE
FIVE MEDICAL EXEMPTIONS IN
THEIR ENTIRE LIFE. SO IF A
DOCTOR IS SIMPLY HANDING OUT
MEDICAL EXEMPTIONS IT'S AN
INDICATION. THAT SOMETHING IS
WRONG. IN MY HOMETOWN OF SAN
DIEGO ONE DOCTOR IS RESPONSIBLE
FOR OVER A THIRD OF THE FIVE
HUNDRED MEDICAL EXEMPTION IN
THE SCHOOL DISTRICT. SHE
ADVERTISED QUITE FRANKLY YOU
WOULD SIMPLY SEND YOUR MEDICAL
RECORDS TO HER SHE WOULD REVIEW
THEM NEVER SEE THE CHILD IN
MEET WITH A WHOLE GROUP OF
FAMILIES TRITE MEDICAL
EXEMPTIONS. LATEST GENERAL
WE'RE NOT GETTING BETWEEN A
CHILD AND THEIR POSITION. WE'RE
GETTING BETWEEN A PARENT WHO IS
OUT SEEKING EXEMPTIONS AND A
PHYSICIAN WILLING TO WRITE THEM
IN MASS. AND EVEN IF THAT
HAPPENS THIS WILL STILL BE
REVIEWED. BY ICAL PANEL.
THEY'LL BE DUE PROCESS
OPPORTUNITY TO APPEAL IT. AND
THE ONLY ONES THAT ARE EVEN
REVIEW A BALL R. WITH THOSE
DOCTORS WHO HAVE WRITTEN OVER A
FIVE YEAR ORDER SCHOOL THAT
FALLS BELOW THE HERD IMMUNITY
STANDARD THIRTY SECONDS MISS
GONZALEZ IT'S BEEN AMENDED IN
WAY THAT ACTUALLY SOLVES THE
PROBLEM WE WERE SEEKING TO
SOLVE. IT'S CLEAR THAT WE NEED
TO ENSURE THAT WE DON'T AGAIN.
SUBJECT OURSELVES TO MASSIVE
MEASLES OUTBREAK I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR MY VOTE. DAVIS HAS ALSO
THE SERVICE AREA YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I RISE IN NOT
SUPPORTING THIS BILL AND I SAY
THAT WITH QUITE A BIT OF.
RELUCTANCE AND HESITATION
BECAUSE AS A CO AUTHOR OF THE
FIRST BILL. TWO SEVENTY SEVEN
FOUR YEARS AGO I. AND EXTREMELY
SUPPORTIVE OF VACCINES ALL OF
MY THREE CHILDREN HAVE BEEN
VACCINATED AND WILL CONTINUE
BEING VACCINATED. YET THERE'S A
BIT OF AN OVER REACH IN THIS
BILL THAT I JUST CANNOT COME TO
SUPPORT. COLLEAGUES WERE TRYING
TO ESTABLISH A PERFECT LEGAL
SYSTEM THAT IS IMPENETRABLE. TO
PROTECT A NOT SO PERFECT HEALTH
CARE SYSTEM. SOME OF OUR
VACCINATIONS HAVE NOT. BEEN
UPDATED IN OVER FIFTY YEARS.
SCIENCE IMPROVES ON A DAILY
BASIS. WE HAVE HEARD IMMUNITY
LEVELS OF 92% IN THE STATE. THE
MEDICAL EXEMPTIONS HAVE GONE UP
TO POINT 7% IT MEANS WE HAVE
ALMOST EIGHT PERCENT. OF
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE NOT
COMPLYING. WHY AREN'T WE
SPENDING THE MONEY ON GOING
AFTER THAT 8% THAT'S GONNA BUT
CREATE A BETTER HEALTH OUTCOME
AND IN FACT IT COULD
POTENTIALLY GET US TO THE 9596%
HERD IMMUNITY LEVELS THAT WE
SEEK. EVER SINCE PASSING TO
SEVENTY SEVEN. LA SCHOOLS HAVE
IMPROVED BETWEEN 223% EVERY.
EVERY SUB SUPERINTENDENTS
DISTRICT IN LA WE HAVE SIX OF
THEM HAS GONE UP. AND THEY'RE
ALL WITH THE EXCEPTION OF ONE
THE WEST SIDE. THEY'RE ALL OVER
90% SO IT'S WORKING. IN FOUR
YEARS TIME SINCE THE
IMPLEMENTATION WE'VE SAID WE'VE
SEEN TO SEVENTY SEVEN WORK. BUT
NOW WE'RE TRYING TO GO AFTER.
POINT 7% WHICH AS OF TWO MONTHS
AGO IT WAS EXEMPTIONS OF. FORTY
ONE FOUR THOUSAND ONE HUNDRED
ELEVEN INDIVIDUALS. WE'RE GONNA
SPEND ALL THIS . IN ORDER
TO HAVE CONTROL THIS IS AN
ISSUE OF CONTROL NOW. BECAUSE
THE SPOT IN THE AMONGST THE
SPONSORING ORGANIZATION. THERE
AREN'T DOCTORS ON STAFF THAT
ARE PUSHING FOR THIS. THEY'RE
PAID LOBBYISTS. SO. AND BY THE
WAY IF WE ARE GOING TO GO AFTER
UNSCRUPULOUS DOCTORS. WE CAN
HAVE MUCH MORE COST EFFECTIVE
LEGISLATION THAT ADDRESSES THAT
SPECIFIC ISSUE. NOT CREATE A
PROCESS THAT'S GOING TO COST US
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK MY COLLEAGUES
TO DECLINE SUPPORTING THIS BILL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISTER
SORRY MR MURATSUCHI YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
I. WOULD HAVE GIVEN MY
COLLEAGUE FROM SAN DIEGO A
HEADS UP IF I KNEW THERE WAS
COMING UP TODAY BUT- THIS IS MY
HEADS UP. I BELIEVE IN SCIENCE
I AM FULLY VACCINATED MY FAMILY
IS FULLY VACCINATED. AND I
BELIEVE THAT. WE DO NEED TO.
PROMOTE VACCINATIONS SO THAT WE
ACCOMPLISHED THE HERD IMMUNITY
AT ALL SCHOOLS IN ALL
COMMUNITIES. BUT I ALSO FEEL
THAT WHILE THE GOAL AND INTENT
OF THIS BILL IS THE RIGHT CALL.
THAT THIS BILL IS NOT THE RIGHT
SOLUTION. I AGREE WITH MY
COLLEAGUE FROM THE SAN FERNANDO
VALLEY. THAT IF THERE ARE BAD
ACTORS WE SHOULD FOCUS ON THE
BAD ACTORS. THERE ARE ALSO TWO
OTHER MAJOR CONCERNS THAT I
HAVE. ONE WHICH I HAD A CHANCE
TO TALK WITH THE AUTHORED THE
BILL DOCTOR PAN. WHICH IS. THE
CONCERN ABOUT. A CHILLING
EFFECT ON LEGITIMATE MEDICAL
EXEMPTIONS. YOU KNOW I AS A
LAWYER I KNOW THAT. THAT IF I
KNEW THAT I THAT IF I DID
SOMETHING THAT IT WOULD TRIGGER
INQUIRY AND A REVIEW. BY A
PUBLIC AGENCY WHETHER THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH OR
THE STATE BAR OF CALIFORNIA.
THAT I WOULD BE RELUCTANT TO
ENGAGE IN THAT ACTIVITY. AND AS
DOCTOR PAN AND I WE BOTH.
AGREED THAT. WE WANT TO PROMOTE
AND SUPPORT LEGITIMATE MEDICAL
EXEMPTION SO THAT CHILDREN
DON'T GET HURT. AND YET WHEN WE
HAVE THIS THRESHOLD WHERE A
DOCTOR ISSUING FOR. OR MORE
THAN FOR MEDICAL EXEMPTIONS.
THAT THAT WOULD TRIGGER THE
REVIEW BY THE DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH THAT INEVITABLY
WILL HAVE A CHILLING EFFECT
ESPECIALLY I'VE MET WAS SEVERAL
PARENTS. BOB WHO HAD TO TAKE
THEIR KIDS TO A GENETICIST OR
AN IMMUNOLOGIST THESE
SPECIALISTS WHO WERE WHO WERE
IT RECEIVE THE REFERRALS FROM
THE PRIMARY CARE PHYSICIANS YOU
KNOW WHO SPECIALIZE IN THESE
MORE. COMPLICATED OR NEW WANTS.
CASES THE CASES IN THE GRAY
AREAS AND A FOR THESE POSITIONS
IT'S EASY FOR THEM TO GO BEYOND
THE FOR MEDICAL EXEMPTIONS A
YEAR I THINK YOU KNOW WITH THIS
THIS LIMIT ON THIS BILL IT'S
GOING TO HAVE A CHILLING IMPACT
ON LEGITIMATE MEDICAL
EXEMPTIONS AND I FEAR THAT THAT
WOULD BE BAD PUBLIC POLICY THAT
MAY LEAD TO SOME CHILDREN. ARE
BEING INJURED. LAST BUT NOT
LEAST THERE IS THE DATABASE.
THE DATABASE NOW HAS PERSONALLY
IDENTIFIABLE INFORMATION GOING
OF IT BEING COMPILED BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF MEDICAL OF A
PUBLIC HEALTH AND BEING ABLE TO
BE SHARED WITH OTHER. PUBLIC
HEALTH AGENCIES. WHY DO WE NEED
TO HAVE THE PERSONALLY
IDENTIFIABLE INFORMATION IN
THERE I MEAN I THINK GIVEN ALL
THE EMOTIONS ARE AND THE
VOLATILITY OF THIS ISSUE THERE
ARE PARENTS AS WELL AS
POSITIONS THAT RAISED WITH ME.
THE CONCERN ABOUT. BEING
DISCRIMINATED AGAINST FOR
HAVING A MEDICAL EXEMPTION OR
FOR ISSUING A MEDICAL EXEMPTION.
YOU KNOW I THINK. WE CAN
IMAGINE YOU KNOW LIKE ANY OTHER
DISEASE THAT. INVOLVES
SENSITIVE INFORMATION SAY LIKE
HIV IF THERE WAS A HIV DATABASE
WITH PERSONALLY IDENTIFIABLE
INFORMATION. I THINK THERE IS A
LEGITIMATE CONCERN I DON'T SEE
THE REASON WHY WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO GO AFTER THE BAD
ACTOR PHYSICIANS WHY DO WE NEED
TO COMPILE A DATABASE OF
CHILDREN AND THEIR PARENTS
THIRTY SECONDS WAS MEANT THAT
CONTAIN THAT THAT THAT NAY
SUBJECT THEMSELVES THAT THEY
MAY BE SUBJECT. TO UNLAWFUL OR
INAPPROPRIATE ACCESS TO HACKING.
BOTTOM LINE I THINK THIS BILL
IS OVER BROAD IT'S THE RIGHT
POLICY GOAL BUT IT'S NOT THE
RIGHT SOLUTION. I ASK MY
COLLEAGUES NOT TO SUPPORT THIS
BILL. MR OBERNOLTE YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. MISTER SPEAKER I
RISE IN OPPOSITION TO SB TWO
SEVENTY SIX I WANNA MAKE IT
CLEAR I AM A FAN OF VACCINATION
I BELIEVE IN VACCINATION.
VACCINES ARE UNEQUIVOCALLY ONE
OF THE GREATEST ACHIEVEMENTS OF
HUMAN CIVILIZATION AND THEY
HAVE MADE A GREAT MEDICAL
PROGRESS FOR OUR CIVILIZATION
THE LAST HUNDRED YEARS. BUT. I
DON'T THINK EVEN THE AUTHOR OF
THIS BILL WOULD NOT ARGUE THAT
VACCINES. ARE WHOLLY WITHOUT
CONSEQUENCE. WHEN THE TIME CAME
TO CHOOSE FOR MY OWN CHILDREN
WHETHER NOT TO VACCINATE MY
WIFE AND I HAD A CAREFUL
CONVERSATION ABOUT IT AND WE
DECIDED THAT VACCINATION WAS
APPROPRIATE. AND I THINK THAT
THAT WAS THE RIGHT DECISION.
HOWEVER SOMETIMES VACCINATION
HAS SERIOUS CONSEQUENCES AND I
HAD A MEETING WITH A WOMAN
EARLIER THIS YEAR IN MY
DISTRICT OFFICE A CONSTITUENT
OF MINE WHO MADE THE DECISION
OF ACTION I HER DAUGHTER. THE
NEXT DAY HER DAUGHTER WOKE UP
AND COULD NOT WALK. AND SHE
SPENT THE NEXT SEVERAL YEARS IN
PHYSICAL THERAPY LEARNING HOW
TO WALK AGAIN THAT IS
TERRIFYING. NOW I REALIZE THAT
THAT HAPPENS RARELY BUT IT DOES
HAPPEN. AND SO THE DECISION TO
VACCINATE IS SOMETHING THAT
PARENTS SHOULD BE ABLE TO MAKE.
THE CHOICE. THIS BILL TAKES
THAT DECISION AWAY FROM PARENTS
DOWN MOST CORROSIVE LEE IT
SENDS THE MESSAGE TO PARENTS.
THAT THEY'RE NOT RESPONSIBLE
FOR MAKING THE DECISIONS THAT
INFLUENCE THE HEALTH OF THEIR
CHILDREN AND WE KNOW THE
PARENTS ARE THE NUMBER ONE
SOURCE OF POSITIVE INFLUENCE IN
OUR CHILDREN'S LIFE. WE NEED TO
TRUST THEM TO MAKE THOSE
DECISIONS AND IF YOU ARE
WORRIED ABOUT. THE LACK OF
VACCINATION AND THE LOW
VACCINATION RATES IN SOME OF
OUR SCHOOLS THEN I WOULD SAY WE
NEED TO DO A BETTER JOB AT
EDUCATING PARENTS ABOUT THE
PROS AND CONS ABOUT VACCINATION
ABOUT DISPELLING SOME OF THE
MISPERCEPTIONS ABOUT
VACCINATION. AND GIVING PARENTS
THE TOOLS THAT THEY NEED TO
MAKE THE APPROPRIATE DECISION
THIS IS NOT THAT RIGHT TOOL I
URGE A NO VOTE ON SB TWO
SEVENTY SIX. DOCTOR WOULD YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS I COME
FROM A SCIENTIFIC BACKGROUND.
AND AS A HEALTH CARE PROVIDER.
AND IT'S DISTURBING TO ME THAT
SOME HAVE LOST FAITH IN SCIENCE
AND IN THE MAJORITY OF HEALTH
CARE PROVIDERS. I KNOW SET TO
SAY SB TWO SEVENTY SIX IS ABOUT
A LOT OF EMOTION. I AND HOWEVER
THE BILL AS IT'S AMENDED I
BELIEVE IT PROTECTS THE DOCTOR
PATIENT RELATIONSHIP. IT
PROVIDES AN APPROPRIATE PROCESS
TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC. FROM
DOCTORS WHO ABUSE THE MEDICAL
EXEMPTION PROCESS AND GIVE
STATE PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICIALS
THE TOOLS TO IDENTIFY AND
PROTECT SCHOOLS AND COMMUNITIES
WHERE WE LIVE. WORK AND WORKING
UNITY IMMUNITY IS AT RISK.
THERE ARE LEGITIMATE MEDICAL
EXEMPTIONS AND THOSE WILL BE
PROTECTED IN THIS BILL. THE I
WOULD. RESPECT MY COLLEAGUES
FROM SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA OF
WHO'S SPOKEN ABOUT THIS I
HAPPEN TO REPRESENT SOME
COMMUNITIES WHERE THE
IMMUNIZATION RATE IS VERY VERY
LOW. SO WHY YOU HAVE MADE MAYBE
HAVE MADE GREAT STRIDES IN SAN
FERNANDO VALLEY OR OR LOS
ANGELES WE HAVEN'T IN OTHER
AREAS OF THE STATE. AND THE
EDUCATION PART IS A CHALLENGE.
THE ASSERTION THAT VACCINES
CAUSE AUTISM HAS BEEN HAS BEEN
DEBUNKED. YEAH WE HEARD IN OUR
HEALTH COMMITTEE HEARING. A LOT
OF PARENTS WHO SIMPLY DON'T
BELIEVE THAT. WE SIMPLY HAVE
LOST FAITH IN SCIENCE AND I I'M
I AM DISTURB BY THAT. WHILE NO
BILL IS PERFECT I BELIEVE THIS
BILL MAKES GREAT STRIDES IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION. WE AS MEDICAL
PROVIDERS PROVIDE INFORMATION
ALL THE TIME EVERY TIME I DID A
PROCEDURE I WAS RESPONSIBLE FOR
THAT. I DON'T BELIEVE IT DOES
HAVE THIS WILL HAVE A CHILLING
EFFECT. IF YOUR MEDICAL
PROVIDER DOING THE RIGHT THING
BY YOUR PATIENT. HEDGING YOUR
BETS WERE FUDGING MAYBE FORGET
YOU OR JUST YOU KNOW LET ME
JUST DO THIS SO THAT I YOU KNOW
THAT SO WE CAN MOVE ON. NOT THE
RIGHT THING TO DO YOU'RE DOING
THE RIGHT THING BY YOUR
PATIENCE. YOU SHOULD HAVE NO
FEAR IF THE DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH AND WANTS TO LOOK
AT YOUR EXEMPTION. AND THERE
WILL BE AN APPEALS PROCESS AS
WELL. SO IT'S NOT THE END OF
THE ROAD. AND THE GOAL IS THAT
YOU KNOW I MY HOPE IS THAT
PARENTS WILL HAVE A HAVE A-
HAVE A ROLE IN THAT AS WELL. MY
BIGGEST FEAR IS NOT MEASLES. MY
BIGGEST FEAR IS THE NEXT THING
THAT COMES ALONG MAYBE IT'S PER
TOSSES MAYBE IT'S SOME OTHER
DISEASE THAT WE HAVE ALL FOR
ALL INTENTS AND PURPOSES A
RADIC HATED. DO WE NEED TO GO
BACK THERE I DON'T BELIEVE WE
DO. I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
RIVAL. THANK YOU DOCTOR WOULD
THIS MATHIS YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS. I TO
RISE IN OPPOSITION OF SB TWO
SEVENTY SIX. AND. THEY THERE
ARE SO MANY REASONS TO GET INTO
WE COULD TALK ABOUT GIVING MORE
POWER TO ANOTHER GOVERNMENT
AGENCY AND THE CURRENT BACKLOGS
WITH THE ENVY DOJ AND THE FACT
THAT EVERY SINGLE AGENCY THAT
WE HAVE CURRENTLY HAS A BACKLOG
IT SCARES THE HELL OUT OF ME TO
THINK THAT WE WOULD HAVE A BACK
LOG ON GETTING APPROVAL. FOR
OUR KIDS. NOW. YOUR KNOWN I'M A
FATHER WITH A CHILD WITH SPINA
BIFIDA. CHILDREN WITH SPINA
BIFIDA. THE ESSENTIALLY WHEN
THEY TELL YOU. THE LIST OF
THINGS YOUR CHILDREN IS NOT
ALLERGIC TO IS MUCH SMALLER
THAN THE LIST OF THINGS THAT
THEY ARE ALLERGIC TO. AND GOING
TO GET MY SON VACCINATED LIKE
I'VE GOT ALL MY OTHER CHILDREN
VACCINATED ANDAS I'VE SAID
BEFORE ON THIS FLOOR. THE
ENTIRE FAMILIES VACCINATED THE
CATS THE DOGS THE HORSES
EXEDRA. ARE VACCINATED IT'S NOT
ABOUT VACCINES IT'S ABOUT
CHOICE IT'S ABOUT. BEING ABLE
TO SCHEDULE THINGS OUT. MY SON
JUST STARTED T. K. THIS YEAR.
AND BECAUSE OF HIS I. E. P. FOR
SCHOOL HE'S STILL ABLE TO GET
STATE. BUT HIS TWIN SISTER
EIGHT NO THERE WAS THERE WAS
ONE SHE DIDN'T GET TO START
SCHOOL UNTIL WE WENT
RESTORATION AND GOT HER INTO
GET ANOTHER VACCINE. JUST OVER
ONE. IN THAT'S RIGHT NOW THAT'S
EVEN BEFORE THIS. THE FACT THAT
WE'RE GETTING INTO THESE
CONVERSATIONS OF. A GOOD DOCTOR
VERSES A BAD DOCTOR THESE GUYS
ARE JUST DOING IT FOR THE MONEY
WHAT WHAT I FIND EXTREMELY
IRONIC IS DURING THE DAYS OF
MEDICAL MARIJUANA PRESCRIPTIONS
NOBODY IN THIS BODY BATTED AN
EYE. OVER DOCTOR SIGNING
PRESCRIPTIONS FOR MARIJUANA NOT
ONE WIN PASS ANYTHING ON THAT
THAT WAS OKAY I WAS COOL.
GRANTED IT'S LEGAL NOW SO
WHATEVER. BUT NOBODY BATTED AN
EYE THAT ABOUT BAD DOCTORS
WRITING PRESCRIPTIONS. SO NOW
ABOUT HERD IMMUNITY WERE
WORRIED ABOUT SUCH A SMALL
PERCENTILE. THAT IT'S WORTH
INCREASING OUR BUDGETS TO A
STATE AGENCY WITH NO GUARANTEE
THEY'RE NOT GOING TO SCREW IT
UP. I LINE A LOT OF THE
SENTIMENTS WITH THE MEMBER FROM
SAN MARINO VALLEY IN BIG BEAR
AND THESE OTHER AREAS WE NEED
TO DO. MORE ON THE PUBLIC
EDUCATION SITE. MY MEMBER FROM
WHAT WHY HUMBOLDT MENTIONED YOU
KNOW IT'S HARD TO GET THE
EDUCATION OUT OF SPECIAL ROLE
AREAS I REPRESENT THE THIRD
LARGEST DISTRICT ONE OF THE
MOST RURAL DISTRICTS IN THE
STATE. AND WE DO HAVE TO DO
MORE ON THE EDUCATION SIDE WITH
THROWING MILLIONS OF DOLLARS.
TO INCREASE THE BUDGET OF A
STATE AGENCY MEMBERS THIS ISN'T
GOING TO HELP US. THIS IS JUST
GONNA HARM BILLS WERE ACTUALLY
TRYING TO HELP. IN INTEL WE'VE
GET THESE BACKLOGS AND ALL OUR
DEPARTMENTS FIXED DMV FIX. DOJ
FIXED I DON'T HAVE ANY FAITH.
IN ANY OF THESE AGENCIES
GETTING ANY MORE MONEY OR
GIVING PE
MAKE SPECIALLY OR SOMETHING AS
SENSITIVE AS VACCINES THE
GOVERNMENT DOES NOT BELONG IN
THAT RELATIONSHIP. IT NEVER HAS
THERE'S ALREADY LAWS ON THE
BOOKS TO GO AFTER BAD DOCTORS
AND I THINK WE'D BE BETTER OFF
TAKING OUR TIME TO USE THOSE.
INSTEAD OF SAYING HELL THE
ANSWERS BIG GOVERNMENT MORE
MONEY ASK FOR A NO VOTE. THANK
YOU MISTER MATHIS DOCTOR QUIRK
MEMBERS IF YOU LIKE WE
RECOGNIZE PLEASE RAISE YOUR
MICROPHONES RIGHT NOW. DOCTOR
QUIRK. YES IF YOU ALLOW.
PARENTS TO. VOLUNTARILY BY
GETTING A FAKE. MEDICAL
EXEMPTION OUGHT NOT TO
VACCINATE THEIR KIDS. WHAT
YOU'RE DOING IS YOU'RE CREATING
FREE RIDERS. PEOPLE WHO ARE NOT
GONNA TAKE THE VERY SLIGHT RISK
OF A VACCINE. AND THEN HAVE THE
POSSIBILITY OF HURTING THE
PEOPLE WHO REALLY DO DESERVE
THE MEDICAL EXEMPTIONS BY
MAKING IT MUCH MORE LIKELY THAT
MEASLES OR ANOTHER DISEASE
PRINT TOSSES. ARE BECOMES A
THREAT THROUGHOUT THE STATE SO
I ASK YOU NOT TO ALLOW FREE
RIDERS THANK YOU. A DOCTOR
QUIRK REST GALLAGHER DIRECTNESS.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS YEAH I THOUGHT IT WOULD
BE APPROPRIATE YES WERE
CONSIDERING THIS BILL TO HEAR.
FROM SOME OF OUR CONSTITUENTS
AND- I RECEIVED THIS LETTER.
YOUR RECENTLY FROM A YOUNG LADY
THAT I GREW UP WITH. AND I
NEVER REALLY KNEW HER HER STORY
UNTIL. SHE SENT ME THIS LETTER
AND I JUST WANT TO READ TO YOU
A PART OF THIS PERMISSION TO
READ MISTER SPEAKER WITHOUT
OBJECTION. SHE WRITES MY
FAMILY'S CHOICES ARE RIDICULED
RIDICULED CONSTANTLY ON NEWS
STATIONS SOCIAL MEDIA TV SHOWS
AND MOVIES. ALL THESE OUTLETS
ARE TELLING ME THAT VACCINES
ARE COMPLETELY SAFE. THEY TELL
ME MY CHILD WILL BE JUST FINE.
TELL ME THE SIDE EFFECTS ARE
MILD AND VERY RARELY.
UNEDUCATED AND DON'T KNOW
SCIENCE. AND I'M GETTING MY
INFORMATION FROM FACEBOOK
THAT'S BECAUSE I'M NOT A DOCTOR
I CANNOT POSSIBLY MAKE THIS
DECISION FOR MY CHILDREN. THIS
IS SIMPLY NOT TRUE. THE FACT IS
I AM VERY EDUCATED ON THIS
TOPIC AND HOW IT MAY
SPECIFICALLY AFFECT MY FAMILY
AFTER HUNDREDS OF HOURS
REVIEWING OUR MEDICAL HISTORY
REVIEWING CDC'S WEBSITE READING
VACCINE INSERTS AND SPEAKING TO
DOCTORS AND OTHER MEDICAL
PROFESSIONALS WE HAVE DECIDED
AND BEEN ADVISED TO NOT
VACCINATE OUR CHILDREN. AT THIS
TIME. WE HAVE RECEIVED A
MEDICAL EXEMPTION FROM A
LICENSE PEDIATRICIAN BECAUSE OF
OUR OWN PERSONAL HEALTH.
REACTIONS OF VACCINATIONS AND
ARE FAMILY'S MEDICAL HISTORY. I
SELF AND LIKE MOST OF THE MOMS
AND PERRANCE. I KNOW AND HAVE
DONE MUCH RESEARCH AND DUE
DILIGENCE BEFORE MAKING A
DECISION ABOUT VACCINATIONS
EACH CHILD IS DIFFERENT.
THEREFORE EACH DECISION IS
DIFFERENT AS WELL. A BOARD
CERTIFIED PEDIATRICIAN AND THE
CDC OUR LARGEST RESOURCES AS
WELL AS OTHER GOVERNMENT
WEBSITES IN MAKING HEALTH
RELATED CHOICES FOR MY CHILDREN.
AS ALL PARENTS PROBABLY AGREE I
WILL STOP AT NOTHING TO PROTECT
MY CHILDREN. I SPENT HOURS
STUDYING WAYS TO BETTER DEVELOP
MY KIDS SKILLS TO HELP THEM
GOING TO GOOD PEOPLE AND
CONTRIBUTE IN A POSITIVE WAY TO
SOCIETY. WHY WOULD I NOT TRY TO
MAKE THE BEST DECISIONS FOR MY
CHILDREN WHY WOULD I NOT
QUESTION A RESEARCH SUGGESTED
BACK IN VACCINATIONS WHY WOULD
NOT SEEK OUT MULTIPLE
PHYSICIANS OPINIONS WHY WOULD I
NOT READ. WHAT THE CDC HAS TO
SAY ABOUT EACH VACCINE AS A MOM
I WILL ALWAYS WEIGH THE RISKS
AND BENEFITS TO DECIDE WHAT IS
BEST FOR MY CHILDREN. I WAS A
COMPLETELY NORMAL GIRL AT THE
AGE OF FIFTEEN BEFORE THE
GARDASIL VACCINE. I WAS DRIVING
AND THEATER AND SPORTS. I LOVE
HANGING OUT WITH MY FRIENDS AND
BEING INVOLVED IN CHURCH. I GOT
MY SECOND ROUND OF A THREE PART
VACCINE AND CAME OUT WITH A
HEADACHE UNLIKE ANYTHING I'D
EVER EXPERIENCE. AFTER A MONTH
OF CONSISTENT HEADACHES
MIGRAINES IN A MONTH OF SCHOOL
I WAS ADMITTED TO THE HOSPITAL.
I SPENT THREE DAYS IN THE
HOSPITAL IN AN MRI SHOWED MY
BRAIN WAS SWOLLEN. WHAT TOOK
PLACE IN THE NEXT THREE IT WAS
OUT OF A HORROR MOVIE. MY HAPPY
GO LUCKY SELF WAS REPLACED BY A
HOLLOW GIRL WHO CAN ONLY SEE
DARKNESS. A MONTH AFTER LEAVING
THE HOSPITAL I WAS BEING
ADMITTED. INTO AN EATING
DISORDER REHAB AND BEING
MEDICATED FOR DEPRESSION
ANXIETY AND BORDERLINE
PERSONALITY DISORDER. NO ONE
UNDERSTOOD WHY IT CHANGED SO
DRASTICALLY MYSELF INCLUDED.
SINCE THEN I'VE HAD I'VE BEEN
MEDICATION FREE AND NEVER ONCE
FELT THE WAY I DID THEN. HAS
SPENT MANY YEARS DETOX IN MY
BODY I KNOW THE GARLIC GARDASIL
VACCINE BECAUSE THIS. YEAR'S
LATER MY SISTER AND HER SON
REQUESTED I GET A TEED UP. AND
THE FLU SHOT I DID. I THOUGHT
MY HEART WAS GOING TO STOP IT
WAS BEATING SO FAST AND
PAINFULLY I WAS TERRIFIED. I
HAD BOTH OF THESE SHOTS AT
DIFFERENT TIMES AND DAYS BUT
THE SAME REACTION BOTH TIMES.
WHEN MY HUSBAND AND THIS HAD
THE SECOND ROUND OF MMR WHEN HE
WAS ALMOST SIX AND SHORTLY
AFTER. HE HAD HIS FIRST SHE'S
SEIZURE. FROM THE TIME IS SIX
TO THIRTEEN YEARS HE LIVED HIS
LIFE WITH SEIZURES GOING TO THE
DOCTOR CONSTANTLY FOR LABS AND
TESS. THOSE SEVEN YEARS CHANGE
HIS LIFE AND LIMITED HIS
DESIRES AND CAPABILITIES AS A
CHILD. THESE SIDE EFFECTS THAT
MY HUSBAND AND I. HAD HAD TO
THESE VACCINES ARE LISTED ON
THE CDC'S WEBSITE. THERE ARE
THOUSANDS OF FAMILIES WITH
SIMILAR STORIES TARS THROUGHOUT
THE UNITED STATES. WITH ANY
SMALL OR LARGE RISK WE TAKE IN
LIFE THE AS US IN CALIFORNIA
CITIZENS WE SHOULD HAVE THE
FREEDOM TO MAKE THESE CHOICES
FOR OURSELVES. AND OUR CHILDREN.
YOU KNOW WHEN THEY'RE- BUT I
THINK YOU SEE. THIS IS A VERY
REAL CHOICE AND THESE ARE
PEOPLE MAKING VERY EDUCATED
CHOICES ABOUT THEIR FAMILY.
THIRTY SECOND THIS GALLAGHER
THIS YOUNG WOMAN'S. STORY
HASN'T BEEN ABLE TO GET TOLD
ENOUGH HER VOICE HASN'T BEEN
HEARD ABOUT THAT IT HAS BEEN
RIDICULED. AND I'VE HEARD IT
RIDICULED IN THIS CHAMBER AND
I'VE HEARD IT RIDICULED IN
THESE HALLS. AND IT WOULD NEVER
BE ACCEPTED UNDER OTHER
CIRCUMSTANCES. AND I THINK WE
NEED TO REALLY LISTEN TO THESE
VOICES TODAY THAT'S WHO WE ARE
MAKING LAW FOR. PEOPLE JUST
LIKE THIS YOUNG WOMAN WHO HAS
TWO CHILDREN. AND IS RAISING
THEM IN TRYING TO DO THE BEST
SHE CAN FOR THEM EACH AND EVERY
DAY. WHAT ARE YOU DOING TO
THOSE FOLKS WHO ARE MAKING
EDUCATED DECISIONS WHO OF
EXPERIENCES. IN A VERY REAL WAY.
NOT A NEBULOUS WAY BUT A VERY
REAL WAY. NATIONAL CONSIDER
THAT WE WERE CONSPIRING WE VOTE
ON THIS BILL TODAY THANK YOU
MEMBERS THANK YOU MISS
GALLAGHER. MISS WALDRON GARBAGE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS BEING SURPRISED AT THIS
BILLS COMING UP TODAY I
SCRIBBLED SOME NOTES SO I SAW
THIS BILL IN HEALTH COMMITTEE
AS WELL AND URGENT NO VOTE IF
THIS BILL GOES BETWEEN THE
DOCTOR AND THEIR PATIENTS IN
THIS BILL IS NOT ABOUT VACCINES
IT'S ABOUT THE EXEMPTION
PROCESS TO FILL CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL VACCINE MANDATES. THE
BILL IN AN UNPRECEDENTED WAY
HANDS OVER THE JURISDICTION OF
REVIEWING AND REVOKING THE
MEDICAL OPINIONS OF PHYSICIANS
FROM THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
BOARD TO THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
INSTEAD OF A WHOLE SILLY
AFFECTING DOCTORS MEDICAL
OPINIONS WHY NOT JUST
INVESTIGATE THE FRAUDULENT
MEDICAL EXEMPTIONS. I MEAN
CERTAINLY WERE POINTING TO OF
THE HANDFUL OF DOCTORS THAT
THEY'RE LOOKING AT WHY ARE WE
DOING THAT WHOLE SALIH
AFFECTING PATIENTS ALL OVER THE
STATE. HEARING FROM PARENTS WHO
HAVE VACCINE INJURED CHILDREN.
WHO ARE UNABLE TO OBTAIN A
MEDICAL EXEMPTION FOR THAT
CHILD FOR A SIBLING HOPING TO
PREVENT ANOTHER VACCINE INJURY.
AND THEY'LL THEY'LL BE UNABLE
TO GET THAT GRANTED. WHILE
IMPOSING RESTRICTIONS ON THE
DOCTORS IS NOT HOW HEALTHCARE
SHOULD BE RUN IN OUR STATE.
VACCINATION IS A HEALTH
TREATMENT AND SO SERIOUS HEALTH
TREATMENT LIKE OTHERS BECAUSE
THERE'S ALL KINDS OF SIDE
EFFECTS THERE'S ONE AS A PARENT
I HAD TO SIGN THAT I AGREED TO
ALLOW MY SON TO HAVE THE
VACCINATIONS. SO IT'S A HEALTH
TREATMENT GIVEN TO OTHERWISE
HEALTHY INDIVIDUALS. THIS
SHOULD NOT BE TAKEN LIGHTLY WE
NEED TO EMPOWER PARENTS WE NEED
TO EMPOWER PHYSICIANS. IT'S
ABOUT THE DOCTOR PATIENT
RELATIONSHIP AND GOVERNMENT
SHOULDN'T BE IN THE MIDDLE OF
IT ORIGINAL. DOCTOR REGULAR
DIRECTNESS THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND YOU KNOW I TOO WAS
SURPRISED THAT THIS BILL WAS
GOING TO COME UP TODAY BUT I'M
PROUD TO ADD MY VOICE AND
SUPPORT THIS MEASURE IN MY
THREE TERMS OF BEING HERE IN
THIS LEGISLATURE I'VE ONLY FOR
ONE DAY SAT ON THE HEALTH
COMMITTEE AND IT WAS ONE SB TWO
SEVENTY SIX CAME BEFORE THE
ASSEMBLY THIS YEAR. AND I WAS
PROUD TO VOTE TO SUPPORT THAT
BILL THEN BECAUSE OF THE
QUESTIONS THAT I ASK AND RATHER
THAN MAKE A STATEMENT I
ACTUALLY WANTS TO REFLECT ON
THOSE QUESTIONS THE QUESTIONS
THAT I ASK FOR TO THE MEDICAL
BOARD IS THIS A TOOL IN WHICH
YOU NEED TO BETTER PURSUE YOUR
GOAL AND THEIR ANSWER WAS YES
AND SINCE THAT COMMITTEE
HEARING THEY HAVE THEN COME ON
TO SUPPORT THIS BILL. AND IT IS
BECAUSE OF THAT THAT I BELIEVE
THAT WE NEED TO HELP CONTINUE
TO SUPPORT FAQS THE NATION'S
FOR OUR STATE AND THAT'S WHY I
ASK YOU SUPPORT SB TWO SEVENTY
SIX TODAY THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER THANK YOU ARAMBULA MUCH
COOPER YOUR RECOGNIZE MEMBERS
OF THE LIKELY RECOGNIZE RAISE
YOUR MICROPHONES NOW I WILL
MAKE THIS VERY SHORT IN APRIL
SOME COLLEAGUES THIS ROOM AND I
WERE IN EUROPE WE TOWARD THE
WILL OF WORLD HEALTH.
ORGANIZATION LISTEN THE TOP
DOCTORS IN THE. YOU GO ON
AMAZON THERE FOURTEEN FIFTEEN
SIXTEEN BOOKS THAT HAVE BEEN
ACCURATE INFORMATION IS ARE
MEDICAL DOCTORS TALKING. OKAY
IT'S NOT OF US HERE. THAT'S A
BIG ISSUE WORLDWIDE AND
MISINFORMATION THAT'S WITH THE
BIGGEST ISSUE. IS THAT THE
PEOPLE LOOK TO THE INTERNET
TURTLES THINGS. AND THEY'RE SO
MANY BOOKS OUT THERE THAT HAVE
BAD INFORMATION THAT'S A BIG
ISSUE WITH THAT HOW DO YOU
FIGHT THAT. INFOS BELIEVE WHAT
THEY READ ON THE INTERNET. THIS
MAKES SENSE TO ME. BUT A LOT OF
FOLKS DO BELIEVE IN THAT AND
THAT'S THE BIGGEST ISSUE
WORLDWIDE RIGHT NOW THE VACCINE
HASN'T TO SEE THAT'S PRETTY
HEAVILY OF DOCTORS TALKING
ABOUT THAT. IN ADDRESSING THAT.
THANK YOU MISS COOPER MS REYES
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS. LIKE
MANY OF YOU I ALSO MET WITH
MANY OF MY- CONSTITUENTS. IN MY
DISTRICT OFFICE AND ALSO HERE
IN SACRAMENTO. I MET WITH MANY
PARENTS AND PEDIATRICIANS. POST
THE SP TWO SEVEN SIX. THE
STORIES FROM THESE PARENTS
REGARDING THEIR CHILDREN WERE
HEARTBREAKING. PARENTS WANT TO
PROTECT THEIR CHILDREN. THAT'S
WHAT WE ALL WANT. I ALSO MET
WITH MANY PARENTS. AND
PEDIATRICIANS. IN FAVOR OF THE
PROTECTIONS BEING OFFERED BY
THESE VACCINATIONS. ONE OF THE
MOTHERS ASKED ME SHE SAID
ASSEMBLYMEMBER WHY IS IT. THAT
I CANNOT SEND TO MY CHILD WITH
THE PEANUT BUTTER AND JELLY
SANDWICH TO SCHOOL. BECAUSE OUR
CHILDREN WITH PEANUT ALLERGIES
YET YOU'RE TRYING TO TELL ME
THAT I SHOULD TAKE SEND MY
CHILD TO SCHOOL AND KNOW THAT
THEIR OTHER CHILDREN WOULD NOT
BEEN VACCINATED. WHERE IS WHERE
IS THE PROTECTION THAT YOU'RE
TELLING ME ABOUT THEIR. AFTER
MEETING WITH THE PARENTS AND
WITH THE PEDIATRICIANS I TALK
TO THE AUTHOR I FOUND OUT ABOUT
THE MOMENTS I ALSO SPOKE TO THE
CHAIR FROM OUR- HEALTH
COMMITTEE. I LEARNED ABOUT THE
AMENDMENTS THAT WERE BEING
OFFERED IN THE WERE BEING
ACCEPTED WHICH PROVIDED GREATER
PROTECTIONS FOR PARENTS.
SEEKING THESE EXEMPTIONS. I
ALSO RECOGNIZE THAT THERE WAS
MORE BEING DONE IN AMENDMENTS
TO PROVIDE PROTECTIONS FOR
PARENTS. WHO WANT TO SEND THEIR
CHILDREN TO SCHOOL AB EXPECTED
THAT THEIR CHILDREN WERE ALSO
GOING TO BE PROTECTED. WE TALK
ABOUT CHOICE WE TALK ABOUT
DECISIONS BEING MADE BY PARENTS.
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT NEEDS TO
BE PROTECTED THERE'S NO
QUESTION ABOUT THAT. BUT WE
HAVE TO RECOGNIZE THAT A
DECISION IN THE CHOICE MADE BY
ONE PARENT. COULD ADVERSELY
AFFECT OTHER CHILDREN ON
KNOWINGLY. THAT IS OF GREAT
CONCERN FOR ME. I WANT TO
EMPOWER THE PARENTS I WANT TO
EMPOWER PEDIATRICIANS. BUT I
ALSO WANT TO BE SURE THAT OUR
CHILDREN OUR CHILDREN ARE
PROTECTED WHEN THEY DO GO TO
SCHOOL. FOR THIS I URGE AN AYE
VOTE. MS AGUIAR-CURRY YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. MEMBERS ARISES A
PROUD CO AUTHOR OF THIS BILL
AND A GRANDMOTHER. SB TWO SEVEN
SIX IS ABOUT PROTECTING
MEDICALLY FRAGILE CHILDREN WHO
CANNOT GET BACK CITY VACCINES
FROM THOSE WHO SIMPLY CHOOSE
NOT TO GET VACCINES. UNDER THIS
BILL AN EXEMPTION THAT IS
GRANTED FOR A TRULY NECESSARY
MEDICAL REASON WILL HAVE NO
ISSUES. THE AUTHOR HAS WORKED
ON THIS BILL TO ENSURE THAT
THERE ARE PROTECTIONS FOR
DOCTORS AND PATIENTS AND A
STRUCTURE IN PLACE FOR DUE
PROCESS. I URGE YOUR AYE VOTE.
I URGE OF FOR MY GRAND CHILDREN.
THANK YOU FOR THE THOUGHTFUL
DEBATE MEMBERS. MS GONZALEZ YOU
MAY CLOSE. I'M GONNA TRY TO
ADDRESS A FEW OF THE THINGS
THAT I HEARD I'M SORRY MY. I AM
NOT A DOCTOR BUT MY HANDWRITING
APPEARS LIKE ONE. FIRST I TOO
AM SURPRISED THAT WERE TAKEN UP
THIS BILL TODAY SO FOR THOSE
WHO ARE SURPRISED. THAT HAPPENS.
FIRST VACCINES ARE CONTINUALLY
CONTINUALLY EVALUATED IN
MONITORED THROUGH THE VACCINE
DATA SAFETY. GROUP AFTER PAN I
AND THEY HAVE BEEN SO IT'S NOT
AS A FIFTY YEARS AGO THERE WAS
A VACCINE PUT OUT WE'VE NEVER
MONITORED THE SAFETY OF IT AS
WELL. AGAIN THERE OVER A
HUNDRED SCHOOLS. THAT DIPPED
BELOW THE 90% COMMUNITY
IMMUNITY RIGHT AND ONE LOWER
THAN FIFTY. I WANNA BE CLEAR A
CHILD THE MEDICAL EXEMPTION IS
CONSIDERED VALID UNTIL IT'S NOT
SO FOR A CHILD HAS A MEDICAL IN
A MEDICAL EXEMPTION NO MATTER
WHAT REASON IT EVEN IF IT GETS
EVALUATED BY THE DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH. THAT CHILD GETS
TO STAY IN SCHOOL ALL THE WAY
THROUGH THE PROCESS EVEN APPEAL
PROCESS UNTIL ITS FINAL SUCH
IMPORTS OF PEOPLE WHO ARE
SAYING THAT WE'RE GONNA HAVE A
BACKLOG WE DON'T NEED TO WORRY
ABOUT THAT THE BACKLOG IS IN
FAVOR OF THE CHILD STAYING IN
SCHOOL. I THINK THAT'S AN
IMPORTANT FEATURE. THIS BILL.
IS SPONSORED BY DOCTORS. AND
IT'S SUPPORTED. BY
PEDIATRICIANS. IMMUNOLOGIST
ONCOLOGIST THEY ALL WANT THIS
BILL. THEIR ORGANIZATIONS WANT
THIS BILL. YES YOU CAN ALWAYS
FIND A DOCTOR TO WHO DOESN'T
BUT LET'S BE CLEAR WHO IS
SPONSORING THIS LEGISLATION.
MOST DOCTORS WANT THE RIGHT
THING TO BE DONE. AND I THINK
THAT'S AN IMPORTANT FEATURE TO
REMEMBER. IT'S ALSO SUPPORTED
BY THE MEDICAL BOARD AND I
THINK THAT THAT'S IMPORTANT
BECAUSE THE MEDICAL BOARD KNOWS
THAT THEY CAN'T INDIVIDUALLY GO
SEEK OUT DOCTORS TO WRITING
EXEMPTIONS WITHOUT PARENTS
COMPLAINING THE PARENTS ARE
SEEKING THESE EXEMPTION SO
YOU'RE NOT GONNA GET A
COMPLAINT. AND IT'S NOT GOING
TO BE DRIVEN IN THE SAME WAY.
AS FAR AS THE DATABASE I KNOW
THERE IS SOME CONCERN.
DEPARTMENT PUBLIC HEALTH DOES
HAVE A DATABASE ON HIV POSITIVE
PATIENTS ON STDS AND I'M
CANCER. THIS ISN'T SOMETHING
NEW SO I KNOW THERE WAS CONCERN
BEING BROUGHT UP LIKE WHAT WE
DO THIS ON OTHER DISEASES GUESS
WHAT WE DO. IT'S THE DEPARTMENT
OF PUBLIC HEALTH. THE
RESPONSIBILITY IS TO KEEP THE
VAST MAJORITY OF US SAFE FROM
COMMUNICABLE DISEASES AND TO
UNDERSTAND MORE ABOUT DISEASES.
AS THEY COME UP. WE ALSO HAVE
THE OPIOID. DATABASE AS WELL
THAT I THINK MOST PEOPLE IN
THIS FOR VOTED FOR. THE
INDIVIDUALS ALSO ALREADY SHARE
IT WITH THEIR SCHOOL DISTRICT.
AND I WOULD SUGGEST THAT
HOPEFULLY THEY REALIZE THAT
INFORMATION IS ALSO HACKABLE
JUST LIKE YOUR INSURANCE.
DEPART COMPANIES DATABASE JUST
LIKE YOUR DOCTORS DATABASE. SO
I UNDERSTAND NONE OF US WHAT
LIKE THAT IDEA OF OUR
CHILDREN'S MEDICAL HISTORY
BEING HACKABLE. BUT IT'S THERE
AND IT'S ALREADY THERE. I'M NOT
A DOCTOR. AND I'M GLAD THAT WE
HAVE THE SUPPORT OF DOCTORS IN
THE LEGISLATURE BUT I'M A MOM.
AND THAT'S WHY I HAVE ALWAYS
FELT SO STRONGLY ABOUT. THIS
BILL. IN TWENTY TEN. WE HAD TEN
DEBTS IN CALIFORNIA BECAUSE A
WHOPPING COUGH TEN BABIES DIED.
THAT THAT'S AGREED BY EVERYBODY
THE DOCTORS THE PUBLIC HEALTH
ADVOCATES THE AUTOPSIES THEY
DIED FROM WHOOPING COUGH A
PREVENTABLE DISEASE. I HAVE A
PERSONAL STORY THAT I DON'T
LIKE TO TALK ABOUT BECAUSE I
DON'T WANT TO BRING UP MY
FAMILY'S MEDICAL HISTORY BUT
I'M GOING TO BECAUSE I. MY
DAUGHTER ACTUALLY BROUGHT IT UP
ON TWITTER YOU SHOULD KEEP HER
CHILDREN OF TWITTER. AND SO.
SHE BROUGHT IT UP IN PEOPLE
START ASKING QUESTIONS ALMOST
ACCUSATORY BUT I HAVE A NEPHEW
WHO HAS A MEDICAL EXEMPTION.
NOW LET ME EXPLAIN HOW THIS
WORKS. I HAVE A NEPHEW THAT IS
IMMUNO COMPROMISED HIS A
WHITNEY A PROBLEMS IT IS
PROBABLY SPENT A QUARTER OF HIS
LIFE. IT CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL.
WE DEAL WITH THIS ALL THE TIME.
HIS MOTHER WOULD LIKE NOTHING
MORE THAN FOR HIM TO BE IMMUNE
AYE IMMUNIZED AGAINST EVERY
DISEASE. BECAUSE IT SEEMS LIKE
HE GOT EVERY DISEASE. THIRTY
SECONDS THE DOCTOR SAYS NO HE
CANNOT HAVE Y. VACCINATION SO
HE CAN'T BE IMMUNIZED AGAINST
MEASLES OR CHICKENPOX. EVERY
TIME IS NOT IN THE HOSPITAL HE
WANTS TO BE AT SCHOOL. BUT
THOSE DISEASES. COULD KILL HIM.
DEFINITELY HE'LL END UP BACK IN
THE HOSPITAL. THESE ARE THE
CHILDREN THE TRULY MEDICALLY
FRAGILE CHILDREN THAT WERE
TRYING TO PREVENT FROM GETTING
THESE DISEASES AND WHY IT'S SO
IMPORTANT. I KNOW PEOPLE FEEL
STRONGLY ABOUT THIS AND I KNOW
ALL THE OPPOSITION IS JUST
ABOUT LOVING YOUR CHILDREN. I
HAVE NO DOUBT OF THAT. A LOT OF
US ARE MAMA BEARS. BUT BEING A
MAMA BEAR MEANS PROTECTING
THOSE KIDS WHO NEED THE
PROTECTION THE MOST. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE ON THIS BILL. THANK WAS
CONSULTS WITH THAT CAR GLOBAL
THE ROLE. THE DESIRE TO VOTE ON
MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL. CLOSE THE ROLE
TELEVISE FORTY SEVEN NO
SEVENTEEN THAT MEASURE PASSES.
ALL OTHER ITEMS REMAINING WE
PASS RETAIN ALL MOTION SHALL BE
CONTINUE SEEING AND HEARING A
FOR THE BUSINESS I'M READY TO
ENTERTAIN A MOTION WITH GERMANS
TO CALL THE RUN MOVES AND MISS
WALDRON SECONDS THIS HOUSE
STANDS ADJOURNED UNTIL THURSDAY
SEPTEMBER FIFTH AT TEN AM IN A
QUORUM CALL IS LIFTED